you
we did have four
cooperative
school district bills yesterday of which
three were
interim studied
and one we held back this is the bill
which we held back which you see the
amendment on
we've noticed that there's some
concer there's at least maybe perhaps
several concerns with it still
and it's one we wanted to use as um
to move forward
so let's open that up the discussion
right now
um
questions on the amending language
remember this was one where
it's attempting to give in a cooperative
school district if you have three
districts that are part of a cooperative
district a b and c a is a large district
maybe it has
three
people on that board
and b and c are both small ones maybe
one and one
and what this is attempting to do is try
to get those people that are
representing that specific district
within the cooperative district
the right to vote for their own
representation rather than being a vote
of the entire
three a b and c
so if you were
running for that one position in c
you would be elected to the board based
upon your own voters in your own
community
that's in your own district that's the
concept of that is what this is trying
so let's look at it and see if it's
doing what we intended to do represent
mullin
thank you mr chair um is there
did this amendment remove the
number of
represent of school board
people that were elected from each
community i remember the original bill
uh had one per community i i
you know and i think we're very much
concerned about that that that's not
going to gel well with a lot of the
agreements it should be the way it's
established if you have three reps in a
you have
one two three that you're voting for so
it doesn't remove it's not one one and
one
so
for instance if
if you're in exeter you're going to have
more school board members than if you're
in brentwood it would be based upon the
agreement that exeter has in that
cooperative school district got it okay
thank you no change no change
yes represent tanner
so
i don't know if it's just early morning
but i've gone through the amendment
and and have it side by side with the
original bill and i was wondering if you
could point out what the difference is
because
i can only find once well one small
difference and that's in line 16 where
you've crossed out at least other than
that it seems to match up perfectly and
i was just wondering if what's the
intent of the of the uh
amendment
melissa
no but
you're right
i i wish we i wish we
wish we talked yesterday so
i'm not sure who is right about what
so i i
okay this is what i'm thinking but
someone that's maybe thinking more
clearly this morning correct me if i'm
wrong so
when i originally
brought this bill forward it was exactly
so
whatever district you were in you would
vote for the candidate from your
district you're right and then when i
did
the testimony during the hearing
it evolved into
let's have equal representation from
each community and i have to be honest
with you i think maybe i was thinking
all along that that was part of the
original bill so when i did the
amendment i had them
remove the word
at least
but i think you're right i'm wondering
wait a minute
no
all right go ahead dave yeah
so thanks rick so i think the the bill
is introduced
the bill is introduced crossed out the
words at least at line 16 which means
that if you had um
a district composed of warner sutton and
new london
uh that
that that each one of those would have
one
representative to the board
and
with with the words at least in there
you could have proportional
representation on the board so i think
the amendment is is an improvement at
least in terms of
proportionality and but it would be up
to the the co-op agreement to define
what the what that proportionality is
and that's something that that gets done
at the establishment of a co-op
or or is maintained during a uh during a
co-ops uh existence
so uh in the amendment that we have here
zero seven eight one h
the change i see we have to do is
okay um
then to
yeah that's exactly right yes
all right so let me ask you this though
the original bill had an effective date
of 60 days after passage
and then the amendment doesn't mention
an effective date because the
amendment's only replacing section 1
i know it's november but you could still
have it at the start of the school year
well you'd have it yeah tie it
july 1st
2023 or something like that yeah yeah
no it won't be fy 22. it would have to
be fy 23
that would be past the july
uh elections except you passed the 2023
elections so i don't see any problem
leaving it 60 days because it will be
i would suggest when the elections are
march january one is too close
you need months to prepare for that and
recruit candidates and for them to
understand the change
you know i would say give them six
months the latest i would say is
september 1st to give districts enough
time to really understand this and that
the cooperative board may have to change
membership based on residency
i i i don't see any problem leaving it
60 days because it's um you know
affecting the next election whenever
that is
so you know it's going to be after 60
days it's going to be the next march but
you know they would know that
this is coming
i'm fine with 60 days but people didn't
seem to be so i was trying to go further
but i think 60 day i agree with you
representative cordelli i think 60 days
this doesn't impact the composition of
the board at all
correct
and that's why we wanted all these
studies going on with disillusionment
with this whole process it's very
convoluted and has a lot of different
agreements from town town
um
this has been an issue we've had for
every year i've been here on this in
this house and i don't know if we ever
get resolve on it
it's a local
study
well i i
you know i think it gets to what was
stead in our hearing one man one vote
right now the larger district
can determine what the makeup is
if they can capture a few votes in the
other town
now it where it would hurt if you had
the three and the one and the one two
and three is
on the same page but there may be some
people in the minority in a
which could swing over and be with a
smaller towns and you may get a
different outcome as board makeup
yeah
in my local co-op
i'm in tuftonboro but i would elect the
school board
representative to the co-op from ossipee
i have no idea who that guy is or who
that lady is
um you know but i would know who the
tuftenborough candidates would be so i
think that
this amendment is
right in line with
no it's not ready
what you want is you want
to take out the at large
uh election possibility you want you
want
i'm trying to figure out what what the
whole thing is like in in the co-op that
um is local to my uh district um
each town
within has a representative right but i
vote for the ossipee representative and
the brookfield representative that's
that large
no they're not at large
they're there there's a uh there's an
ossipee representative there's a
brookfield representative by everybody
but when you vote
i vote for those representatives also in
addition there are three at-large
representatives um that are specified as
at-large representatives so you know it
would be fine to have everyone vote for
the at-large representative but the
brookfield representative i think should
be elected by brookfield
right and that uh and well in kearsarge
that's what they do but they have it's
proportional because warner and new
london are bigger towns right so they
get two two representatives right and
then each of the other
uh five towns have one representative
but you only vote for the representative
in your town exactly right well
okay that's what it does yes that's what
so are we
good to go with this by just taking that
ore out and we get them to make the
change if we don't make the change then
we're going to have a problem on the
floor
and you're going to have to have a floor
amendment or then you're going to have
to hold off and
get it fixed in the senate and that
doesn't always bode well either
do we know if any co-op districts
um
have their elections coming up within
this
yeah so no my co-op wouldn't my co-op is
a co-op of one yeah
and what's very unusual the others have
pulled out
and so
so
okay
so i guess we can go on with the regular
business right now
mr chairman for something as minor as
the or i would suggest we could vote on
it right now if you want and then i had
this discussion with another minor
change we detected
the other day and when i
this it wasn't with anthony it wasn't
with jeff one of the others over there
and they did some discussion with their
boss and the only way it can get changed
now is the ways i just mentioned it
floor amendment
and
i don't think we should send something
out especially if we have days in which
we can get this done
i agree i agree yeah
okay so we will get this repaired now
okay because it is it okay if i just say
to everybody here just like from the
bottom of my heart thank you so much
because you've all been so supportive
and i hate to say nurturing right
because we're not kids but no but you
really have you've been very supportive
and walked me through this and
it's been great and i just wanted to say
really i really appreciate it thank you
all
well thank you for
okay so now we have our business for
today
and
the first bill which we have in the dock
70. oh yeah excuse me i'm wrong page 73.
relative to the best interest of the
student for a change of school or
assignment
and
represent cordelia i look to you for a
motion
thank you i'd like to move
ought to pass on house bill 1373.
and representative hobson you have a
motion or a second i'll second that okay
thank you very much so we have a motion
for ought to pass on 1373 relative to
the best interest of the student for a
change of school or assignment
representative cortelli being the maker
of the motion do you have any discussion
yes thank you um
i apologize for not being able to be
here for the
public hearing on this so if i might
explain a little bit of the background
on this bill
this bill is the result of
several calls
from a parent in
southampton to
various legislators and the commissioner
of education
and the commissioner
contacted me about
this legislation
this parent is in southampton
their high school students
under a tuition agreement go to a high
school in amesbury massachusetts
it's a five-year agreement
this parent
does not think much of the amesbury high
school
he would like his
children to be educated in new hampshire
he said he pays new hampshire taxes
the school is better he would like his
child to be educated in new hampshire
and was just looking for the ability
somehow to go
to the school board and asked
out of this tuition agreement to
amesbury
massachusetts
so
in discussions with the commissioner we
thought that
maybe using the best interest of the
student
would be a way to do it
so that's what i attempted in this um
legislation and you can see on line four
all we added was
the
consideration of parental concerns
in uh talking to the superintendent
school board about the best interest of
the child and then in light 13
adding to the
criteria
to be considered we added the transfer
to a public school or public academy in
new hampshire
to help out
this family and possibly other families
in the district
i'll also mention that there was a
companion bill
from this individual's
state senator
um but that bill in the senate got uh
referred for interim study
so this bill is now the only
family
take their case to the school board and
ask for
further discussion from the second
um i echo everything that glenn said and
actually um i have been familiar with
this uh case for a few years now so
they have not found resolution and i
would um support this measure
okay i i do have a question and then
representative luno
this legislation comes underneath
manifest education hardship that's is
that correct
correct
um
then what what is the criteria for a
superintendent to make a decision to
transfer
what is a manifest education hardship or
what is in the best interest of the
student is i just want to go to another
school that is partially part of the
problem on the original case we had
up in lisbon years ago in the court case
um which brought about uh the best
interest of the student the parent did
not like what was happening in the
smaller in lisbon and want to go
elsewhere
i think it was in easton
and and so um
is this
i don't like what's going on in amesbury
uh enough of a criteria to say we will
the parent just wants the ability to go
to the school board
and ask um
basically for out of this tuition
agreement so that his child can go to a
new hampshire school uh high school um
and that was the reason for the two um
yes representative hall
so he can't
ask
like you're saying he can go to the
school board and ask for the transfer he
can't do that right now
um
i i don't think that
in statute there's any provision for the
superintendent of the school board to um
let him out of that tuitioning agreement
that is in place for another five years
so he could ask but he would be told no
i think that he has tried and he was
told
that their hands are tied basically by
the tuitioning agreement short of any
so so um
this is this has been going on for a few
years now what i'm hearing is this has
been going on for a while
and sort of following the the steps
uh laid out in 193 colon three
the parents
the family has asked
the superintendent for a best interest
determination
okay and then and then the
superintendent
roman 1 i
so if the superintendent does not find
that it is in the best interest student
change the parent or guardian may
request a hearing with the school board
of residence
to determine if the student is
experiencing a manifest educational
hardship under paragraph two so did the
i i am not positive of um
all the steps that were followed um the
only uh uh correspondence that i have um
dates back to um uh september i'm not
sure what other correspondence there was
and what other uh
chain of events there might have
the reason i'm poking on this is is that
i don't really see how the the change at
line four
um
is necessarily going to change the
outcome in in roman one i the
superintendent's determination
but the the existing statute does have a
process that moves from best interest to
manifest hardship
and uh and manifest hardship is a is a
different um
you know has a different standard
associated
uh with that and i think
culminates with a roman three
um the state board so it can be
after you've then appealed to your local
school board
for a manifest hardship hearing and then
the
school board does not find
in
in favor of manifest hardship then you
then bring it to the state board of
education
and this is in roman 3
may permit the child to withdraw from
the school
[Music]
for such time as the state board deems
necessary
and then 3a
student reassigned under this section
um
so now we're talking about reassigned to
a school in the in the in the state
because it talks about adm and stuff
like that
i guess i'm not sure how this this does
anything right
um
if i could yes go ahead um
uh
as you'll see in line six and seven
um
there were
options given to the superintendent
if they find that it's in the best
interest of the child
to
there was three options previously
including um sign within a the
assignment within an assigned school
transfer to another public school
uh transfer to a public school or a
private school
for this situation where there was a
tuition and agreement and they're in
a school in massachusetts and
would prefer to go into a school in new
hampshire
and that's also why we added
in four
for parental concerns would be a
consideration that would be taken into
account by the superintendent to uh
determine if it was in the best interest
of the child
sure i i
um
yeah and i'm sure that
it'd be hard to believe that the that
the parents have not made their concerns
known to the to the superintendent if
this has been going on
two years so so uh the superintendent
keeps coming to the same conclusion
you know doesn't apply
here
and
i don't see how the change in four
is going to affect
it's going to change how the students um
uh what the outcome is and and then on
lines 13 or 14 i don't see how those are
any different than what's on lines 11
and 12
because um
uh public school public academy are
already defined in statute
as being schools approved by the
department
and schools that are approved by the
department are located in the state of
new hampshire
uh let me let me get in this a little
bit because you know
i'm conflicted with this um i just want
to make sure we're doing it i want to
take the situation of ainsbury and this
student out of the picture
uh and let's say there's another student
down there that does have you know and
when i look at the best interest of a
student it says within a
statute
the superintendent shall consider the
students academic physical personal or
social needs
if in fact the superintendent says no i
can't see any need for the transfer you
not you haven't demonstrated to me et
cetera et cetera so then the parent says
well okay then i'm going to request a
manifest education hardship
and if that's unsatisfactory of course
you can go to appeal the state board but
the manifest education hardship has to
do this
such hardship must be so severe
pervasive or persistent that it
interferes with or limits the ability of
the student to receive an education
we had discussed this many times when we
made the changes and tweaked this not
tweaked it rewrote it
and it took us must have been four years
to get the thing completed and we worked
with the school boards association and
they helped us write this
if a parent comes up and says well i
want to move because of this particular
reason that one
i would say no
now what happens if the kid does have
these severe issues which demonstrate
the need for another bullying or
something's going on
the child needs to be in another
situation
now the district only has one tuition
agreement and that's with amesbury
then does the superintendent have the
right to establish another tuition
agreement
that is
to send the kid to a school in new
hampshire
absolutely
superintendents do this all the time
well the tuition agreements are
generally made by your school board
because you're following the dollar the
dollar comes to the resident district
then it files to the tuition district to
pay for the tuition cost sure sure but
in the in the case of of of both best
interest and manifest educational
hardship the superintendents in both
districts can can agree on a zero
tuition in fact it says in the statute
the tuition can be waived
um and and in most cases the tuition is
waived because you've got that that that
uh superintendent what what is it called
professional courtesy
um where where i mean i think that's
what what what it's about that's the way
we used to operate but now we operate
based upon the three criteria that are
in this building but but it's in it's
laid out in there yep yeah um
yeah the students transferred to a
public school public academy or approved
private school in another district
yeah so they could they could
the superintendent could have
the superintendent could have an a um a
conversation with the superintendent in
another district let's just pick on
oyster river or win a cunning
and um and and come to an agreement that
sure we'll uh
either with a tuition agreement that
would have to be subject to approval of
the board and i think that's in there or
tuition waiver and uh and that's a good
thing too because if if the
receiving district
ever had a similar issue they might be
able to go to um to hampton and say hey
can you help us follow the next line of
thinking here
item three in here is one of the places
you can transfer to to another district
it's already in law
yeah could i ask where you were reading
the uh manifest education hardship um
uh definition
in the first column at the bottom okay
and can i also add that
specifically in southampton they only
have one school that goes up to eighth
grade so it's my understanding that
students high school students can
tuition into winnicunit
or amesbury and i was not privy to the
conversations that uh the commissioner
brought up with glenn so i don't know
what the situation is right now with
that student
and i had not heard
since the last piece of legislation went
through
i think it was last term
where it where it went i didn't even
know that the bill was
put into interim study so i i don't have
anything to add on this and i'm sorry
no no
go ahead yeah the the um
the the changes that were made and i
forgot when it was a year or two ago to
manifest educational hardship were um
were were developed over i think several
i think there were several swings at the
back to oh we had too many together
and it was a very comprehensive uh
change that that
put
sort of logic and process to um to the
best it added best interest i think
didn't it it added this well best
interest is prior to manifesting right
but it is segregated
came first and then right it wasn't all
jumbled together
and so so the process is much more clear
now and and um
i hope the family understands the
process because i think the existing
process
could could give them
a lead to the resolution that they're
looking for okay representative mullen
you have your hand up thank you
under manifest hardship
roman 2h
if the student is assigned to attend a
public school or public academy in
another district because of a manifest
educational hardship the district in
which the student resigns shall pay
tuition to the district to which the
child is reassigned
the school board of the district in
which the student resigns shall approve
the tuition
i mean there is money around yeah there
is no question
thank you chairman i was i was going to
concur as you start to read the the
specification for the manifest that's
what i had highlighted in the book the
exact same thing it just seems to me
that the
the options for the student are already
there without four
that the this is just repetitive um i
understand grilling's pine important
parental concern that's that's an option
you think they already be there but
that's fine but the the number four
makes it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense because they already can send it
to another school district if they
choose to and and they have the option
of how it's gonna be paid it doesn't
have to be a handshake or a professional
agreement
so i think it just sounds like that the
parent
a single parent of the whole state of
hampshire this particular place does not
satisfy the agreement of the
superintendent that's what it sounds
like
but he does the superintendent does have
the option to send him to a different
school
yes represent nelson
thank you mr chairman what about
transportation if that student were to
to come out of massachusetts would the
district have a responsibility to
transport the student to the new school
no we don't have transportation
requirements for high school kids
by law
you can do it in case of emergency
or the the
that exception is in law now that was
done by finance
uh by i think karen umberger made that
change back around 17 18.
yeah
they do but it's optional but it's
optional it's offline by law right
they're not required
adequacy does not provide you money for
that
okay
uh
if i if i could maybe if i could um
contact uh the department and try and
get additional information from them um
before we have
an actual vote on it
i have i have no problem with that but
you might convey to them that my reading
is that we don't need it
that uh line through that the third item
takes care of it
and
the the superintendent has that
authority
already
but it's got to be a manifest education
hardship and in the particular case that
you're talking about i don't think if i
were an administrator i wouldn't approve
it unless there was something really
going on here we start doing this in one
district we're going to get it
particularly on tuition agreements
yes yes exactly
mr chair if i may also say i apologize i
was out that week as well so there was
no information
to be had to this committee so i
apologize we'll get more information
from the department and we will address
this one
so
we're intake we're taking no action uh
so you wouldn't have to you can put down
some discussion that we had
but
we will come back and we will
take this up where we're executing it
the next one on the daca today is hb
1114 relative to education service
providers under the education freedom
account program
i recognize rep representative cordelli
for a motion
uh thank you i would like to move itl on
uh
and we have a second from representing
the hobson uh representative cordell you
made the motion of itl do you have any
discussion
uh thank you mr chairman um
yes i uh
i believe that
um
this
legislation is designed
for a
education service provider
who would be
that does not fit with all the students
in the program as there are a variety of
services that
can be chosen to meet the child's
education
needs um it could be a therapist
it could be the purchase of a computer
from amazon or whoever
a whole variety of different
different options
these criteria to be made available in a
list
would not apply
um and would apply only to a school and
i i think in some instances for a school
even
some of these might not necessarily
be valid
pieces of information to be included on
any list
i also believe that
information on available service
providers
is made available to parents
in selecting education options
further discussion
trebson tanner
thank you um you know one of the things
i think is that uh we need more uh
transparency um i i certainly as one
person would feel a lot better if we had
more transparency in this um
with these types of things i think
you know you have parents that are now
consumers and they're going to be
uh trying to to navigate um
an area where there are a lot of people
clamoring on the outside for their
particular uh money
and um
you know it's it's hard to get consumer
information
um
you know i checked on uh
kearsarge i keep throwing that out but
that's what i'm more familiar with
and checked on their website you know
and and all these things are are listed
along with and and i would suggest that
co-curriculars if there's any um
you know clubs or
uh you know do the students uh have an
opportunity to
to uh participate in robotics or you
know is there is there some
uh other areas that that whatever
educational vendor it is uh is able to
provide them and if if it isn't uh
something that they can provide if they
don't have
um
something uh which i can't imagine well
for example transportation options they
certainly could just put non-applicable
uh you know if it was a remote group so
i don't think it's i don't think this is
a big ask of people um
i think it's it's uh consumer
information you know i really do thank
you
represent porter on then represent like
us
thank you mr chair um
it seems to me i may be reading
we get so many
emails but i seem to remember
a comment or an email that came
that was from
a parent
who was using the efa program
thanking us for this bill because it
would help
them to
find out what's available and help them
make their decision so
i'm wondering
if anybody has
talked to people who are getting efas to
see
what
information they would find helpful i
believe
representative cornell you can correct
me on this but i believe the reason this
bill was written this way
is that these were issues that parents
receiving
vouchers or efas had problems with
nationally
in a survey that was done and so it was
a recommendation
that such a guide be available for
parents
it's a lot of money
people want to make the right decision
and this would help them
thank you
thank you representatives
yeah the program just started this is
all in the works right at the moment
the
scholarship organization talks to every
single parent and answers all these
questions personally
and there is a list it's already out
there i actually have it of all the
potential
providers
but
they are working on this basically they
said their comment on this bill was
[Music]
the program just launched let's let cfs
do the work and tell us what they need
and and let the parents tell them what
they need they talk to them all the time
they're gathering this information this
is a work in progress
and
they are working on this it is something
that they talked about doing all along
and right but right now
every parent they talk to individually
so the parents don't even need this
list to just go to because
they're they're one on one talking with
the organization who's giving them all
the information they need but the in the
organization i mean these
providers they're just now getting
information on them etc and as glenn
said an awful lot of these don't really
pertain
to a lot of the
the um
providers that they have like amazon is
a provider
it by definition it's a service provider
but
this doesn't does not pertain to them
when you have groups
that this doesn't you know this pertains
to like
schools that are accredited and stuff
but things this money gets used on all
kinds of things that aren't just schools
so the organization is in the process of
doing this and finding out what the
parents want we don't know what the
parents want they know what the parents
want because they're talking to the
parents on a regular basis and i have
talked to
people who are getting this and anytime
they have a question they just call
and they get their questions answered
you know it's it's
and yes there will be something like
this but they're finding out from the
parents what they want not us telling
them oh we want this no this isn't
necessarily what they want
the parents are telling them what they
want let's let the parents do that
representative cornell
i think if the scholarship organization
is doing it anyway i don't think it will
hurt to put it in statute that they
should be doing it and i most states or
that are already doing this do have a
directory of what's available and
sometimes parents don't know what they
want until they see it written down and
they can say oh
look at this list i think i want that
they may not think of it unless they can
see it and and i think it's important
that they know that if they're choosing
something doesn't include what they are
looking for they may not think to ask
that before they sign up
for a service provider so i don't think
it's harmful to put in statute that the
service or the
scholarship organization will do this
anyway
but and strange as it is i did get
thanked on twitter for providing
services for
ef for
server for um
educational freedom accounts which was
very strange
but they thanked me for thinking of them
so
okay uh represent hobson and then
represent porter
thank you mr chair um i was hoping that
representative lycus could send us that
a link to that list because i have not
seen it
send it to the whole committee and the
other thing that i wanted to mention is
that at an education conference recently
the children's scholarship fund if if
i'm remembering correctly
was a model for education freedom
accounts throughout the country
apparently other states don't have
framework like this set up yet so i just
wanted to put that out there
representative porter
thank you mr chair
if the goal
as has been stated
many times in this committee is to have
many families taking advantage of
education freedom accounts
i'm wondering how
as far as i know in new hampshire there
are two people
working with the scholarship
organization
how will those two people be able to
handle
inquiries from
hundreds maybe thousands of more people
in the next couple of years who are
taking advantage of this um that's why i
think it would be helpful to have it in
a website was people could go through so
they don't get stuck on the
phone line waiting to le till their call
is answered in the future represent
woodcock
thank you chairman
i was
thinking the same lines as
representative cornell uh whenever the
lakers indicated that the scholarship
organization already talks to all the
individuals and and
all the people individually and gives
them all the information that they
already have it
then if it's already there then it'd be
easy to put in in print
and
be available to all parents who are
looking to decide where they want to go
um
and convenient you know 10 o'clock at
night or sitting there on there and do
it when you're working and have a chance
to do that
the second part tonight and she's
absolutely correct there are some things
that are not applicable uh like the
amazon you put not applicable that's
simple so you know so the parent knows
this this doesn't have that i i also
think things like the school discipline
problem uh policy are important because
we're going to roll my youngster with a
provider i'd like to know what the
discipline policy is and not find out
after we get there something's wrong if
if it's what she says it is it's
available already they talk to them they
tell them individually put it on the net
so everybody can see it they have an
option to use it
thank you thank you representative
cordelli uh thank you uh i would just
point out that the legislation also uh
provides for a parent and service
provider advisory commission um i think
that's uh the place where um
what criteria um to be listed in uh any
directory of service providers um they
would be that would be the place for the
uh
or the uh
pieces of information to be listed
would be determined i think that's the
best place for it and in addition there
is an education
legislative oversight committee to the
program and they will be meeting um in
the middle of march i cannot remember
the exact date um
but um as last i heard there was uh to
be a presentation of the class wallet
system which will
which
is where all service providers are
registered and
basis for electronic payments to those
service providers from the accounts
so i think that there are things uh
going on and um
i don't think that it always requires uh
do what's uh intended in this
legislation i think that
um
parents advisory commission and other
options are available and they certainly
can
come up with what is needed
for information for
parents joining the efa program
perhaps santa luna
thank you very much mr chair so um we're
at the top here of a string of
efa and voucher bills
uh coming coming up and um and you know
it's it's certainly
obvious to everybody that um that that
this is a very partisan issue
um uh
the um we
[Music]
we absolutely were in opposition to um
to house bill 20 when it when it came
through last year and uh and in fact
house bill 20 i think resulted in being
being um
retained uh in committee and then and um
or and was it was it even put on the
table no i think it was retained in
commit
i i think it was retained in committee
um because we didn't have the votes to
pass it and um
and and public
outcry was so strong i think even on
that bill it was like 6 000 something
opposed to it to
a thousand something um uh in favor
of it and um and obviously ultimately it
made its way you know into the into a a
budget that you know a 12 billion dollar
budget that had 129 000
um
uh set aside for um uh for for vouchers
so what what we're doing here
with beginning with house bill 1114 but
also with with other bills that i think
we've
already exact like uh like 1684 which
which would have held
um the program to budgeted amounts and
and with an amendment would have
protected students who were already
involved with the program
yeah yeah but it's not to tear apart the
program but it's to make it responsible
um to taxpayers and make it responsible
to parents and students too and that's
what 1114 is trying to do i agree
that that the language here is a little
clunky because education service
providers yes applies to amazon it's
right in the uh right in the definition
in 194 f
um
i think what representative woodcock
suggested that it's not applicable to
somebody buying a notebook from amazon
um but it's certainly applicable to
education service providers in maybe
more of the classical sense whether
they're a private school or a private
academy or
or or you know tutoring services or
something like that and we heard
directly from from matt southerton uh
with regards to the the i think he used
the term rigorous vetting process that's
in place now
so yes we're at the beginning of the
program representative lucas but they're
doing a rigorous vetting process right
now
and um and so so they have the data to
collect that
furthermore um uh
this
not so much this bill but other bills as
well
are in response to uh to comments that
have come back from the jail car uh
attorneys critical of the rules that
have been presented right now and and
one example of that and and i think this
is also part of
1114.
um is um is you know what's what's the
you know how
how
how safe is my student going to be
with this education service provider and
in fact the current rules
proposed by the department specifically
say the scholarship organization shall
not conduct criminal background checks
on education service providers so i'm
sort of wondering how actually rigorous
this this vetting process is but at
least as far as as it concerns schools
who are education service providers the
name of the administrator the
performance data the written discipline
policy the years in operation
that's all transparency that's all for
the public for for families who may be
considering
um sending their child under the under
194 f
to um uh to a program outside of their
their school district
um and and and have it laid out there so
that they can take a look so i'm glad
representative lucas has that list i'm
glad representative hobson has asked for
that list
um because if that list is available it
should be put up for um uh for everybody
to to look at and um and and and of
course
um these schools must have performance
data too because that's part of the um
the the accountability standards that
that all schools um have
and um
and and
as we go through
you know
1114 but also the others today
um i hope people aren't going to look at
this as being death by a thousand cuts
because that's not the intention of how
we're bringing this forward
we know this is a program that's in
place we know this is a program that's
highly unpopular
with granite staters
recent polls granite state polling has
indicated that uh as well and that we're
just trying to tighten up on this a
little bit for to be responsible for
taxpayers and be responsible for
students and i'll say it again um we
heard we heard the department say it
yesterday that that that that um student
safety is job one well damn it it should
be job one and the fact that it's not in
the rules um
in fact that it's that it's
that it's
that that that the rules state the
scholarships shall not conduct criminal
background checks is just outrageous
okay let's let's uh get back on this
particular topic right here
i
i think that everybody here is anxious
to
look at bills constructively and see is
there a way to improve a program now
i think everybody ought to be looking at
things from that vein
i would approve this bill
if in fact it didn't have a laundry list
of items done oftentimes when we put
laundry lists on things something's left
off i know it says those magic words but
not limited to
um but
we do that often and what we're doing by
writing these laundry lists
we are getting down into the micro
management
of where we belong in terms of whether
we're doing it with the the college
system the university system we're
dealing with high schools we're dealing
with elementary schools
where does the responsibility of
internal administration
and authority come into play
i i concur the scholarship organization
shall compile a directory of public
profiles for each education service
provider listed period
and let the oversight committee let
those that are involved say okay here's
some important elements that the public
should know to make a decision
however that's not the way this reads
right now it goes down and reads all
kinds of things which there there's
going to be some things which are
checked off not applicable
high school doesn't provide
transportation
our elementary schools are not
accredited all of them some are
accredited through the elementary
association but they're not all
accredited we have several high schools
which are not accredited
so
then you can look at other aspects of
that as well so it's there's going to be
n a's on on certain responses i think
that every profile should list
those you know for example amazon
they're not going to be there's going to
be a lot of n a's here
uh down the list but it'd be nice to
have a profile what amazon can offer in
terms of uh
offerings so i i would be supportive of
this bill if we put a period after
listed and let those are responsible to
do it so rick
one of the reasons i think we um
you organize the exact sessions in
groups of like we're doing all the efa
bills right now is so that we could we
could have discussions like this and
possibly even consider amendments that
you know uh to this bill or other bills
after after conversation but but um uh
possibly taking
you know lines one through six
and and knocking out um
essentially knocking out the rest of the
thing so ends at public profiles
and and and relevant data we could just
put relevant data and leave that up to
the the oversight committee leave that
up to the scholarship organization but
at least it provides at least it starts
us in the in the direction of
transparency but i i i and if we really
try to address this so we are
communicating to our public
now i understand that there's some out
there that don't like efas we we got
that message left but we also know
there's 1800 people that do like it they
have kids 1800 kids in the program it's
there for a reason it may be the best
fit for that particular child or that
family um i'm not objecting to the
alternative forms of education in the
state i support it strongly i would like
to see something here where we're no
provider is that the individual parent
we've had that discussion before
or is it is it a parent that has other
kids in the neighborhood coming in and
sitting in that home and they're
providing this small pod
with scholarships funding uh and
education uh a provider obviously is
maybe part of that but you know the
parent it's like a home school and we
don't you know you can homeschool and
and you don't have to go through these
hoops
and we don't put the hurdle so high so i
think there's room for working on this
thing
um if we if we put down what we're
and do it in a way that is going to make
it informative to the parent
and
uh leaving some of what we put in it up
to uh you know the folks which are
dealing with the issue
um
at this point in time i could go with
this bill if you put a period after
listed or you know if you had some other
language to to explain what the purpose
of these profiles is
to communicate to the public here's an
opportunity for you to have you know and
here's what this provider does provide
okay if you're willing to do that then
we will jump over this and we'll come
back to it is that all right so i want
the public to know though that that we
want to see
a program work we want to see every
child
and as i've heard from your team over
there too many times represent luna
every child in this state counts
our demographics shrinking we need every
one of these kids get an education
and i'm all for doing it in any way i
can do it
so let's let's move forward get bring
back that amendment we'll deal with this
for the day
first off the you should have the email
it is being emailed to you about the
providers so you can look at it
um
second off the organization is coming up
with saying you know they're designing a
database they're doing all of that kind
of stuff they're using based on the
questions they get et cetera et cetera
it's happening that's what i was trying
to say before it's happening already
but
i the question is do you know that rules
were passed on friday and do you have a
list of those rules because so many
things that are in these bills that
we'll be seeing are covered by the rules
and some of them are in conflict with
the rules that were passed and they just
got passed so all the arguments all the
whatever was done in jail car they fixed
things they did all this stuff the idea
that
these bills went in based on gel car i
mean friday
friday is when they passed the jail car
and i would ask that when you're trying
to develop this talk to matt southerton
uh you know
he's the one that came in here and spoke
on behalf of this
and and and and involved glenn as well i
i think we're all supportive of
communicating
uh with the public uh so that there's a
way it can be done let's get it done
correctly
and you know and and try to come back
with something that's palatable for all
with that
i i hope it does because you know mother
nature is going to pick up some steam on
friday
and if we don't get our work done guess
where we're going to be the following
week
right back here
and remember guys i wanted everybody to
have the full week off some have got
airplane tickets flying out of here so
there might be some subs that we'd have
to use if we have to come back
for a date
okay so let's do 115
next one on the docket here
relative to the uh to record of
educational attainment under the
educational freedom account program
and um
representative hobson is
yeah that's what i got down here
no she can steal all the fun she wants
i'm the lightning keep us on track
and and i agree with everything you said
about the last bill just wanted to say
that um
i would like to make a motion itl hb1115
is there a second
i hope so
okay thank you thank you uh
so we have a motion made by
representative hopson second by
representative moffatt uh make her the
motion do you care to have any
discussion yes i will briefly say that
efa students often homeschool students
compile information throughout the year
into a portfolio this method has been
approved and for some is a better better
method to measure progress these
portfolios need to be assessed by a
credentialed teacher under current
legislation education freedom accounts
are provided three options for
assessment that are in line with the
current requirements in statute this
bill would take away two options forcing
parents into a single assessment option
that is inconsistent with our currently
approved options this creates
unnecessary burden on families that are
trying to stay compliant with
assessments
providing multiple ways of assessment
allows families to choose the best fit
for them
there is really no reason to test
students participating in education
freedom accounts differently than public
school students
sounds like you got the committee report
already made huh
okay uh so
so let's have some discussion now
represent cornell well i don't
understand the last sentence that you
said that there's no way there's no
reason to
[Music]
test freedom account students
differently than public school students
when all public schools students take
the state assessment exam
so if you're not going to do everyone
how do you
tell if they're doing well in their
other school
other program
because i i think
just said
your last sentence was that they don't
have to do what the public school and
the public school does right well and
when you were giving testimony rep
cornell i believe i asked you what if
students are using different curriculum
to um
to achieve the same goals
it might not look the same the standards
might be arrived at through a different
method so the statewide assessment might
not work for that particular method that
they're using
and i hope that makes sense because
that's all i've got
uh maybe i can just interject uh one uh
bit of information when we were looking
at way back one with the common core
standards
and there was concern from some
districts that they'd like to elevate
above the common core other words to go
beyond
the minimum standards
and we also established at that time
that there could be
they could do that
has to be approved but they can do it
and they can assess with a norm
reference test if they so desire
everybody has to take the statewide
assessment simply that we try to get at
least a 95 percent completion in these
schools in order to sustain
reduction in funds from the federal
government which they can do that if we
don't get to a certain level of
participation on the statewide test
that's a mandatory thing for receiving
the s monies
and we have an application which we
submit
that that gets that approved so there
are multiple ways that we have for
assessing the competencies that we're
doing within the schools because all
school districts
are teaching
uh the curriculum and the instruction
in accordance with how it's been
approved for that particular school
district
and there's no sense for anybody to give
a test if the test is not aligned with
what is being taught at the time it's
being taught you teach us history maybe
one place and one grade level another
grade level x school and another grade
level
that occurs through elementary ed as
well so you want to make sure your
instrument is aligned with your
instruction and your curriculum so and
there's also a movement in this country
and it's been done quite thoroughly down
in massachusetts where they have
portfolios
and capstone projects which com are
following that and the portfolio is a
record of achievement what the child has
done and that's getting away from this
basically and which i'm not necessarily
a real believer in a test saying the
child knows how to apply the knowledge
and skills
that they've been taught
and the portfolio shows more application
of the knowledge and skills so i think
we'd be an error in in subtracting from
how we assess these other two valuable
instruments that are used to to assess
student growth
represented
thank you very much mr chair for for
laying that out and uh and that makes a
lot of sense
um
particularly because the um the 194f
voucher program does not um
specify i don't think it requires the
same set of um of
of you know core
um
curriculum core adequacy or minimum
standards that public schools are held
to
so
so having public school students take a
test that clearly documents their
performance against those those those
minimum state standards is um uh is very
relevant there but to the degree that
that um that
that
about your student
is
is is having their education paid for
through through public taxpayer dollars
and that and that these taxpayers
through their their their
legislators
have
have endorsed the
state minimum standards
wouldn't from an accountability
standpoint they have a right to know how
an efa student is performing
on a test that's um that that does show
their competencies
uh uh
against um you know curriculum that's
that's that's in the that follows the
the state minimum standards
and if the student is
you know is being taught some completely
different curriculum and therefore does
not do well on this test is that really
a good use of taxpayer money
or if they're
using a curriculum that goes way above
the standards and they ace the the test
wouldn't that be a good indicator of a
good use of of taxpayer money
um
so so you know so even though that even
though the test you're right is directed
to to to curriculum that public schools
are taught may not necessarily match up
or align with curriculum that's being
taught to the efa students um
you know i think performance
to that is is a good indicator to
taxpayers about how their investment in
this program which is now over eight
million dollars a year is um is is is
bearing out and i think that's the
intention of of of of uh house bill
1115. so then i'll res why take out a
for example a norm reference test which
the state test is it's normed against an
original norming test scores whether it
be an nce score or
etcetera or growth scale score of some
kind they're comparable between those
two instruments why then not allow a
person to use the iowa test of basic
skills or the california achievement
test
or or that but that's been eliminated
here yeah yeah um
so so i could see maybe maybe bringing
that back
back in
uh as long as as long as the norm rests
nationally standardized norm referenced
achievement tests
um
certainly as long as there were were
enough students being measured against
that test that it was statistically
relevant
nationally um
you know i think maybe we've got some
common ground on on that well to a
degree i'm not there all the way yet
because we have kids in this state that
do not take the statewide assessment
test due to that they may be in a
special service group which there's an
alternative format of of based on their
ieps
their handicapping condition
to demonstrate growth
and that's another another instrument
which we use and uh
there's got to be another way of
measuring growth other than
just this one way and i'm an advocate of
that i'd like to see this as an
opportunity for all our regular ad kids
as well yeah and and um and
does that does that exception process
also apply to i mean if it applies to
public school students it should
certainly apply to
to students
it seems to be a discussion between
yourself and i and i apologize but for
one it's not a voucher program two that
i'm trying to we have to do it in the
state simply because in order for us to
read receive those millions and millions
of dollars annually from the elementary
secondary education act now essa we have
to have that statewide test we have to
have that
if you were to ask uh this education
committee and who sets policy many times
we really discussed that i know that
representative guile and i were on the
same page on this we did not necessarily
believe that this is the best instrument
to be deciding our kids are achieving
that's why we put growth in there
there's other instruments out there too
uh whether it be the the nape or it be
the pisa or whatever that our kids get
involved with or the science tests uh so
um
you know i i think that this whole area
right here is that it gets into
achievement what's the reason for
achievement how do we measure
achievement
and you know we know that some of the
achievement tests out there are
basically in my book
worthless the instructor says so much
time taken away from teaching in the
classroom that they're preparing for
this thing a month ahead of time
and and so i won't go into my tirade
anymore but uh you know how i feel on
this representative porter
thank you mr chair and i apologize for
running in and out of the room okay so
my understanding is that
when the state set up its
assessment program
it was decided that these were the
skills
and the content area that we wanted
our students in new hampshire
to show that they knew what they were
able to know and able to do they set up
the test because this way because they
felt that it was beneficial to new
hampshire to have new hampshire students
show proficiency
in these areas
i'm not saying i agree with it but
that's what it was set up
we hear all the time about how lousy
certain schools are because they are not
meeting the proficiency standard
set up by the state
tests
we hear that when we hear people want to
pull their kids out and put them in a
private school we hear that when people
say they don't want to move to a
community because of their lousy test
scores the public schools are held
accountable
for their performance on these tests
if
our schools our public schools are held
accountable
on the results of these tests
and we're not making other educational
opportunity places also show that
they're doing this job
with the same measurement
how are we going to know that the money
that we're sending
to
private schools or charter schools or
home schools or whatever
are educating the children of the state
to the level that the state has
determined is beneficial to itself
and that's why i think keeping this test
in there as a source
of evaluation for these programs is
vital how else are we going to know are
we going to be comparing these apples
and oranges we've got a school over here
that's just using portfolios well that's
a different way of assessment we've got
a school over here that's using the
gates mcginnity that's a different way
of assessment if we're going to be
determining how excellent our schools
are how excellent our teaching is we
need to be using the same
skill
and that's why
i think this needs to be in there
you know i'm really tired of hearing how
lousy the schools are because only 30
percent are proficient in math now after
the after covert of two years of
disruptions well that's according to
this test
if you don't think this test is valid or
an accurate measurement of what a
student knows and is able to do
why are you bringing it up to make us
feel bad about our public schools our
public schools
are held to such high standards
and i just think
all
education
getting public funding should be held to
the same high standards
thank you for now i got my rant in but
it really makes me angry
thank you
further representative cordelli and then
representative
thank you
getting
back to accountability and
if a school is not achieving as uh
representative porter just was
indicating
um and the proficiency levels are not uh
where they should should be
then parent
might leave well they can't leave in
most in many cases right unless they
have the funds to do so
right so people we're talking about in
this program don't have that ability now
if you want to talk about adding a
criteria
that um if uh school proficiency levels
are below
x they would automatically qualify
regardless of income for an education
freedom accounts then you know then we
can talk
but
the best form i think and we talked
about it last week
i'm sorry
i think i have the floor at the moment
if we want to talk about accountability
we talked about it last week i think the
best form of accountability is parental
accountability
right who knows the children best
if and this program and others similar
to it and even the tax credit
scholarship program if they're not happy
with the education option they can
select a different odd
different education option
parental account affiliate
accountability is the highest form of
accountability
in terms of uh
you know
accountability for public schools is a
whole separate area that we don't need
to go on to uh related to this bill but
i think
to eliminate
a you're
putting criteria
in terms of assessment on many
non-public schools
that might have efa students and
eliminating c
eliminates a whole class of
people in the program as well
and
i view it as
setting the stage
for
changing criteria in the home education
sector as well uh so i am
totally against um
this bill and totally supportive of the
itl motion
see who is that represent like us then
represent woodcock and
rolling around here
go ahead
part of the reason we carefully worded
the first one nationally standardized
norm referenced achievement test number
one is because they're very comparable
but number two because that's what the
private schools do that's what a number
of the private schools do and we didn't
want to make kids who are attending
private schools take
have to take multiple tests
that way
if they take the test at the private
school it is comparable and it is
compared to a large number of students
because those tests that the private
schools do are national
and they do compare and you can look at
how the kids do on this test they take
at the private schools and see how
they're doing you don't have to compare
it
to the state ones
but the other thing is
are special needs kids
they're not coded their parents
are private they believe in privacy they
don't want their kid labeled and i've
heard this from numerous parents they
don't want their kid labeled with a
label that's going to continue with them
for the rest of their life
and if you
and if they have to go to a school and
prove in order to take the the other
test
that
um their special needs and do all of
that that's going to be in the record
that's going to be passed down they're
going to people are going to have access
to it when they go to college people are
going to have access to it when they're
employed sometimes they do not want
their kid labeled they do not want their
kid coded they know what the issues are
they're working with special needs
people they're working whether it's
dyslexia or whatever
those things can make it very difficult
to take this statewide student
assessment for the same reason that kids
who have ieps don't necessarily have to
take this they are measured in other
ways and that's the point of the
portfolio
the parents anybody who's looking at it
can see that they're improving their
learning but they may be
excelling in math and just because
they're very dyslexic they can't spell
they can't write they can read maybe or
maybe not and so you're looking for
improvement they're working with
teachers who specialize in dyslexia
for instance and they're improving and
and great progress is being made with
their portfolio you can see that but
they may still do horribly on a
standardized test because
that's the area they're having trouble
with right
but it doesn't show how they're
excelling accelerating and doing well in
all these other things and there are
colleges they would prefer a portfolio
to a standardized test there are
colleges that would much prefer that
because it's a better
a better way of showing what a kid is
doing what a kid is capable of that's
why there
there are
um
there are both private and public
schools are going to who are going to
portfolios
okay so at any rate the options were
there because we have a wide variety of
students in the program
thank you and we want to keep them there
thank you representative woodcock
thank you channel that um
i do want to go back and and reference
your
opening uh dialogue when you're talking
about the massachusetts
capstone project and those in the
portfolios
capstone projects in massachusetts
typically accompany
and not are in lieu of other
requirements for graduation there are
high school graduation requirement most
schools
massachusetts has we all know the mcas
test which is the standard for
graduation
and they rang the bell is the standard
for graduation so it's all out like
they're accepting themselves by having a
portfolio that is part and parcel of and
is separate from the mcas which is an
assessment and i understand listening to
representative leakers talking about
measuring a different way but an
assessment
in the cash in a portfolio is different
an assessment is where you are at a
point in time it's not how you're making
progress they're not looking at how
you're making progress it's an
assessment where are you now at that
point in time as compared to everyone
else
and we heard the
commissioner of education sitting here
last week
and tell us
that the school curricula across new
hampshire needs to be changed he said
needs to we need these four key things
and he was measuring that on testing
measure that on the results of the four
tests he named the three testing name
that that's his measure
i understand that statewide makes it
look good we have these three tests and
so we'll go back to the old way and take
these four subjects of the key area but
that's what he's telling us when he says
fifty percent of the kids who grew up or
knights undergraduated the high school
graduates had fifty percent quartile uh
that tells us something so he's using
the statistics he's using the numbers of
where we are now you're not looking at
progress and that's the same point of
this that when you ask for a
standardized test for everyone you want
to know where they are and that besides
transparency and taxpayer money the
bottom line is you don't know where are
they and then you see if they're making
progress
the last part and i do uh understand
your point uh rick on section a about
the comparative testing with a private
school but i do take reservation to the
the part about the portfolio evaluation
uh when you're telling me that a teacher
who works in an arm or someone currently
teaching in a non-public school when we
know that 50 of the teachers in charter
school do not need to be certified they
can be anyone
and we call them a teacher
and you take that same piece here if i'm
teaching in a non in a parochial school
you say
susan would you come over and help
evaluate my my youngster's stuff because
you teach in parochial school that
doesn't mean she don't squat but she
does a lot but it doesn't mean she knows
anything so i mean there's not a way to
evaluate that i think that's a huge
error in this whole pro in this this
bill when you go back to that one test
where are they now that's all they're
asking do everyone in the state and we
know special ed youngsters have a
special exemption and we know that
that's been there forever and it needs
to be there
that's all thank you to know where they
are right now you use something like a
star test star math star reading
that will give you the information
throughout the school year this
statewide test you give it in the spring
you get the results back and if you were
here when we heard testimony we'll get
the scores back in october well that
doesn't help the teacher
you know the in fact that the the
results i won't go there you know where
i'm going
so um
there's a lot of ways of measuring where
a child is
and i think we got to be fluid and allow
that to occur
and we're only giving that that
statewide test
because the federal government
and we did eliminate years going by
about eight ten years ago
we used to have a requirement where we
will test for reading writing arithmetic
language arts
science
and social studies was in it
we recognized that wasn't happening
science yes that's happening you know
out of several grades because of the
feds but so now we're not even assessing
by way of a test all those subjects
which we equate to adequacy
i understand but that's exactly what the
commission were looking for the other
day we went back to the four exactly
and the testing so you could get the
statewide understanding and get federal
dollars i understand what it is that's
what i'm saying but that's a measurement
at that point
and there's other ways of getting that
measurement data so i i
represent a hall
let me make it short and sweet
everyone has to take the test everyone
has to take the test whether whoever you
are take the test and i heard we have a
wide variety of students
in the efas
we have a wide variety of students in
the public schools
further discussion
represent cornell this is just i just
want to find out some information i know
when public schools take the test it's
put in the paper it's announced whatever
when the
when the private schools are or whatever
take the nationally standardized
norm referenced achievement test are
those results published like in the
union leader or
anywhere else that is available for
people to see how
their
children are doing if you if you put
like if you talk about like kimball
union or holderness or vermont academy
or any of those schools they don't have
to publish that they won't publish this
if but if they're getting taxpayer money
for their students this is why a school
like a vermont academy or a holderness
will not take
federal dollars they're not going to
have those the not rules but the
regulations in the federal level govern
how they're going to perform so the
schools that take federal
state tax money if you're going to get
it the federal money you're going to
give us some kind of uh you know
assessment as a result of the elementary
secondary education act the original and
subsequent which would be essa okay
thank you
and why do they do that
yes federal dollars
so
it's accountability for use of federal
dollars
yeah we we like to say it's
accountability i you know
i i don't want to go on that
one last discussion
thank you mr chair i'm i'm old enough to
remember before
the federal government got involved in
our state tests we were giving state
tests
back in the 90s before
before the no child left behind act
developing test questions in math for
the state assessments this was well
beyond before the federal government
required it
remember the found remember the
frameworks remember all that that was
all going on yeah we had the frameworks
we had those guidelines and you can go
back another 20 years prior to that and
you were giving
a norm referenced achievement test they
were but they weren't required
no and and the state started requiring
many and i don't know how many districts
were doing it but i know most were
giving some kind of achievement to
figure out you mentioned gates mcginney
that's a test that measures
comprehension and vocabulary so my first
year teaching in new hampshire
in the school i was in we gave a
standardized test that the teachers were
supposed to correct
it never went anywhere it wasn't done we
in fact mine sat in the drawer because i
was new and i didn't know what i was
supposed to do with them until it was
way past the time so
i mean yeah
okay let's uh mad clerk would you please
yes thank you
this is relative to bill house bill
1115 relative to record of educational
attainment under the educational freedom
account program the motion on the table
is itl
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is a yes
representative bone
representative blakis yes represent
moffitt
yes represent hobson yes representative
ford yes representative soti yes
represent nelson
representative luno no
representative waltz no
representative cornell no
from tanner no
representative walner
no oh did i say that wrong
represent mullen no
roseanne woodcock
was that porter no
reserve hall no and chairman ladd yes
so the motion of itl carries 10 to 9.
so you're going to have a minority
cornell okay
okay and
okay being the elementary principal i
want everybody to stand up and shrink
you know shake it out a little bit here
and ralph i want you to drink water over
there
and um
and
and let's take five minutes and walk the
hallway
we want to keep these discussions down a
little bit
because i'm i'm debating whether i have
to let people know whether we're going
to meet next year
the
hcs
yes okay represent four seconds of
motion
um
being the maker of the motion to itl on
1120 uh
represent cordelia would you like to
speak to the motion uh thank you um
mr chairman um
i think that this legislation
um
is intended to put
restrictions or requirements on
that
inappropriate for some
in terms of one year participation
um
history of academic success
i think that
for many types of education service
providers
this is
and
b also
in terms of the administrative rules
requirements
i think that this goes too far
micromanaging if if we want someone to
look at
things
such as this in the future the program's
only a few months old one two
we have an
efa oversight committee
that
meets on a regular basis and
anything in this area i think would be
subject to
that oversight committee and that would
be the place where any adjustments could
be made in the future
and for those reasons i
thank you mr chair
so as the
prime sponsor of 1120 i just want to
make a few statements about the intent
of of the bill
um
generally speaking i am a fairly logical
person
house bill 1120
while it is broad in its scope and that
it touches upon four different things
was born out of the concerns that we
have had with a program that came to be
so quickly
and in a manner that didn't allow for us
to individually look at each one of
these
concerns prior to it's being adopted
so
when house bill 1120 was in fact put
together
by me
and sent to ols we had some
minimal discussion back and forth
between myself and ols about the
language
the intent of the bill is to primarily
look at the safety of students
we're talking about health and safety
standards codes
that
all schools and programs that deal with
students have to comply with in the
state of new hampshire
we're talking about something near and
dear to me and that is background checks
for education service providers
to assure that our kids are not being
put at risk when they are in the company
of an unknown uh adult or an adult
that is recently known
uh as
i understand what has been said by many
speakers this morning about rules and
laws and gel car
but
ols in january answered a jail car
inquiry about
the background check aspect of this bill
and
the inquiry revealed
the ols interpretation
that the scholarship organization is
under no obligation
from rsa 193
to
put together any kind of background
check in fact i'll read from you if
you'll indulge me for a minute uh one
excuse me 194 194f does not grant the
scholarship organization the ability to
require criminal background checks
the rule doesn't actually require the
scholarship organization to have the
education service providers get criminal
background checks rather the rule
requires the organization
to publish any procedures the service
providers happen to use to ensure
background checks take place for their
providers who have
direct access to children the department
and its cover letter to the conditional
approval request states that the intent
of a language is merely to have the
providers post their procedures for
background checks if they have them
to affirmatively require criminal
background checks for any provider
having contact with children
will require further legislation
that sentiment uh is again repeated
on uh
in february that
if the the department agrees that if
criminal background checks were to be
required
we can sit here and we can debate the
merits or lack thereof of any point of
the program but the fact of the matter
is that efas are here
student safety has to be
has to be in the forefront and so i
would ask you
as you're considering this bill
to uh think about the
safety standards both both from an
educational and a physical safety point
of view and to consider whether or not
this bill ought to in fact move forward
thank you thank you very much are there
further
yes represent like us
once upon a time it was apparent it was
a parent's job
to make sure their children were safe
once upon a time we didn't have
background checks
numerous teachers who've done nasty
things in schools passed background
checks
parents still need to be wise
the scholarship organization
has and must have what the procedures
are
if one of these services
providers have any the parents have
access to that the parents can then
decide oh they don't do background
checks i'm not going to choose them or
they can decide i'm going to be present
with my child anytime my child is there
and so i say the people who care most
about the protection of the children are
the parents and it's not like at a
public school where they don't have a
choice where it's decided this is the
organization you're using you're putting
putting your kid on your bus and off
they go
they are choosing what organization to
use how to supervise it all of that so i
say let the parents take care of their
kids thank you
represent tanner
thank you i was just wondering you know
like
when i go to buy um hamburger at the
store
um
you know i i have a feeling that uh
everything's been inspected and things
are are okay for me to eat hamburgers
kind of can can be pretty dangerous if
it isn't uh
done in a proper way
and i just do that routinely
and
i'm wondering uh how many parents
are
doing the same thing they're they know
that when they've sent their kids to
public school
if they're taking the efa to take their
kids out of public school they know
reasonably well that the the school has
you know has fire extinguishers does you
know fire drills
have
minimal safety standards even even our
schools that we identify as schools for
tuition purposes only
have to meet the local health and safety
standards and codes
and
and as a parent just how many things can
you check that
i i think there's a certain thing about
being yes a uh an informed consumer
but you have to have the information to
be an informed consumer and there's
another thing about just being a
consumer and expecting that
uh you know life is gonna
go on and and take it as it is and
so
i really the second part of this i think
um you know complying with state and
local health and safety standards and
codes
and also the the background checks as uh
representative mullen and i and
and attorney fenton have been working on
for a long time uh we're very concerned
that you know predators now
can see
uh you know they they gravitate to
programs that are going to be
providing
the kids that they want to
uh prey on and so uh you know that
i think it's important that we have
these safeguards thank you
thank you further discussion from the
committee
not seeing any discussion madam clerk
yes
this is regarding house bill 1120
relative to education service providers
under the educational freedom account
program the motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is a yes
representative boehm
representative blakis yes representative
moffat
yes
representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes representative
yes
representative nelson yes
representative luno no
or sam waltz no
representative cornell no representative
tanner no
no
and chairman ladd yes
okay itl 10 to 9.
okay
who
wraps them on i will assume
okay
the next bill we have on the docket is
left 11 52 is a bill relative to
verification of eligible students under
the education freedom account program
i'll hand the gavel over to uh
representative cordelli
uh
thank you mr chairman
um
house bill 1152
uh i would call on the chairman for a
motion
yes i'd like to move itl on 11 52.
thank you thank you representative ford
uh and
chairman ladd would you care to comment
on your motion i do it um eligibility
for the program is clearly stated
uh in the in the bill that you have on
line five
where you have less than or equal to 300
percent of the federal poverty
guidelines
as updated annually that's clear
now eligibility for the differentiated
aid which is
you're receiving differentiated aid is
not the same as this eligibility for
the um
the 300 percent level
if you you can receive differentiated
aid
in various categories
such as ell english language learner
special education service you get that
monies you get the monies if you're on
not receiving in the other three
categories for remedial reading
and then you have free and reduced
if you're free and reduced meets the
guidelines in the of the application you
qualify there if you have an iep you
qualify without
any income level at all
especially it's not related to income
and the same thing for english language
learner and the same thing is for if you
have the remedial reading
so
the purpose of verifying eligibility to
it's
you don't have to verify that it's
something that is done through
differentiated aid and processes within
the school which says yes you qualify
for that category of differentiated aid
it has nothing to do with eligibility to
uh
thank you uh
representative ford do you have any
comments
uh representative luno
thank you very much mr chair and um and
thank you very much representative ladd
i think what you what you laid out there
is um is is
generally
is accurate but but i do have a couple
directed specifically to
free and reduced price lunch
and i guess the first is
how do
know whether a student is eligible for a
free and reduced price lunch on an
annual basis and i guess the second part
is how do they do that
well of course differentiated files the
year prior to is where the the monies
are allocated through the state in other
words it's not in the given year
it's based upon monies available from
the preceding year
and yes um the the department does know
students which are receiving services
during any given year they have access
to that information they can do that by
the unique people identifier etc so so a
follow-up on that so let's say let's say
a student has been
home schooled
for the last
picked the number of years
six years
and um and now the efa program comes
into into place
the the students just been having lunch
at home
um uh has no iep
how does the scholar or scholarship
organization determine or the department
determine their their eligibility
for
free and reduce price lunch
differentiated aid or frankly special
education differentiated aid given the
fact that the student as a homeschooler
would probably not have an iep
and
and as an efa student would be
ineligible uh under for faith under idea
um if i could um the scholarship
organization uh it's my understanding uh
gets uh federal tax returns um annually
from um families so that would be used
to determine the free and reduced
eligibility
um representative lakes did you have a
question comment yeah i was just going
to to say that that every year they get
all of that and they check it and double
check it and they actually have people
who specialize in tracking that down and
making sure that it's accurate
because the organization is not just two
people they're part of a national
organization and they have lots of
people who help with fraud and all kinds
of stuff and the other part of it is as
far as ieps go they don't get that money
unless
you know they have
as far as i know they they don't even
get that money because they're not you
know a public school student
um so the
the department's own fact sheet actually
shows that i think nearly 50 percent
of i don't have it in front of me um but
that it actually carried the the number
of students out of the 1635
that were receiving um special education
differentiated aid which i think is
somewhere around 1800 over on top of
base adequacy then those students must
have done all of the stuff that they're
required to do to do that
because they check it all
the uh the number as of november 9th was
88 who received special education aid
0.3 percent
uh representative um
thank you representative cordelli
um so i have a question um
with regards to differentiated aid in
general when you're a public school
student and you have either ell services
or remedial reading services or an iep
there are certain criteria that have to
be met in order for you to retain those
services
so
for an iep kids are tested every three
years for uh ell services and
what is what is the the procedure
for determining whether or not these
students who may have had ell services
at the age of eight
still need the ell services at the age
of 12 or
what if somebody you know at one of our
proudest moments in a public school is
when someone graduates out of special
education
so
how how do we determine whether or not
these students are still in need of
services and
whether or not that makes them
the
to clarify one thing the
the remedial reading is only done at
third grade
if in fact you don't receive other
differentiated aid
so is the differentiated aid for reading
only given the when the student is in
whatever fourth grade if they don't if
they're not ell
if they're not free and reduced
and they don't have a special ed iep
they're not special ed
but they are remedial
they will get this one-time dose of
funds it's a little over 700 bucks
they're about 700 800 bucks one time
only as a third grader
they will not get it again in the fourth
grade all right thank you for that
clarification so that clarifies that one
now in order to receive a money in terms
of special education you have to have an
active
iep
ieps you know that every year they're
looked at there's an annual but there's
also a three-year review a huge review
where you determine whether the
handicapping condition is
correct
needs change or whatever
so that process would have to so you'd
have to have a current active iep to
receive that differentiate that's known
through the department of education
see the english language learner is very
similar
they have that that is there's a
director over there also that's in
charge of that program which would have
that information
you're welcome uh representative porter
so does that mean that um
in this bill they're
they're asking
that those eligibility
um
the eligibility
be reviewed every year
and you don't like that in this bill
because
the department already does that is that
what you're saying
eligibility for differentiated is done
annually yes and that's not but but and
and getting into the efa program has
nothing to do with differentiated a
yes but the amount of money that's
received
scholarship does is determined by
differentiation yes and you will get
that base adequacy amount
and when and this is why when the
scholarship organization has this they
notify doe it takes a while for them to
go through and compute over there
the eligibility status in these
differentiated aid areas that is then
tacked on to the yeah
it comes out on average by the state
around 4 600 for the whole nine yards
yeah so
why wouldn't you do that every year
which is what this bill is asking for
i i they they do that what they what
they what this bill is saying that
there's been a confusion though with
eligibility getting into the program
that 300
level
that that is done once yes
i don't think there's a confusion there
what i'm saying is i i understood this
bill and the purpose of this bill was so
that
that differentiated aid amount could be
adjusted each year depending on the
status of the student each year they're
not talking about
this this bill is not talking about
reviewing the um
income of the family every year they're
talking about looking at the
differentiated aid
amount that the state is contributing to
the scholarship every year so if
you know the first year i i'm an esl
ell language learner
and by the third year i'm no longer
getting that you know to have that if
it's not checked every year how will
the state know
to reduce the payment
uh if i might elsewhere in the
legislation
it requires determination
between the scholarship organization and
the department of any eligibility for
differentiated aid
say that again please representative i'm
sorry if i i can read it to you the
scholarship organization shall in
cooperation with the department
determine eligibility for differentiated
aid subject to any applicable state and
federal laws does it say every year
well i think that's
by definition how differentiated aid is
determined for any student
whether they're in the public school or
in an efa
program
represent tanner
thank you just
because i'm confused at this point
if someone qualifies for
an efa
and they get an amount
that includes differentiated aid
are they guaranteed that amount
throughout the rest of the time that
they are on uh the educational freedom
account
no no
uh representative lagus
yes the information i just got was that
the doe has frl ell and third grade data
internally attached to the kids sas id
the scholarship organization verifies
ell on their end also
parents give them an ell letter from
public school determination
public schools have an ell test
doe knows who these kids are are ready
and for the different as for the money
aspect of it as i said they get
every single year they get that year's
federal
tax
return you know
federal tax information and so every
year
what the child deserves as far as free
and reduced lunch that kind of stuff is
done every year
and then as as as glenn was saying if
they have a iep and it's active that
would be the only way that's why there
are lots of parents in the program who
have kids with special needs and don't
get special needs money because they
don't have an active iep like homeschool
kids wouldn't somebody just coming from
a public school would so all this stuff
that's in here it's already done
it's done now it's been being done the
whole time thank you
any further
comments if not
this is regarding bill 1152 relative to
verification of eligible student
oh i think i missed something i have
eligible student under the educational
freedom account program i think i'm
oh to verification excuse me that's
important of eligible students under the
educational freedom account program the
motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli
yes representative blitchfield is yes
representative boehm yes representative
blakis yes representative moffett yes
representative hobson yes represent ford
yes representative
yes
representative nelson yes perhaps i have
luno no representative waltz no
roseanne cornell no
representative tanner no
no chairman lad yes
great
okay the next bill which we have coming
up is hb 1283
this this is an act relative to the
liability as taxable income of education
freedom account payments i look to
uh representative uh
cordelli for a motion
uh
thank you mr chairman i would move uh
itl
thank you
i would second that so we have a motion
made by representative cordelli seconded
by representative moffett itl is the
motion uh representative cordelli would
you like to speak to your motion
uh thank you
um
i would basically uh
repeat i think what i said during the
the green
and that
this language is uh comparable
the language in statute now is
comparable to every existing education
savings account program in the nation
um and uh to uh the best of my knowledge
as of uh about a month ago um
the and the checking that i did uh
nobody has been taxed on this uh
this funding
so i do not believe there is any need to
to change the language
further discussion representative do you
have any thaad
uh what representative cordelli said
thank you
up to the represent luna
thank you very much mr chair and um
and representative cordelia i appreciate
knowing that um
that other
other states with um with with with
education savings account with these
programs in place
use this language but how many of those
states have their own um state income
tax
uh several uh right right so in that
case state law could be exempting um uh
efa payments from state income tax
that's within the purview of the state
but we're not in that situation here in
new hampshire we don't have a state
income tax and to say this here
would lead one to believe
that they have no federal tax liability
incurred on a payment that was uh that
was made at a parent's direction
and you're it was made through a
scholarship organization but directed
based on a parent's decision not based
on the state's decision to fund a um
a school district with an adequacy
payment so
i do have um um uh opinions verbal
opinions from uh from uh new hampshire
tax experts uh as to that that leading
people to believe this would be
incorrect certainly unethical
and and then and then of course from a
from a federal now we're talking from
the state of new hampshire standpoint
federal tax liability you really have to
wonder why
um
senator cruz has has introduced now
three times
in um in the us senate uh bills to uh to
make
distributions under free it's called the
education freedom scholarship and
opportunity act
uh distributions made under under such
programs it states free from federal tax
liabilities and this bill has failed
every time
so
so i think there's something out there
um um may not know it for sure i don't
know why we lead people to believe that
uh that they would not have a uh
potential for a um for a tax liability
the the language in in 194 f
doesn't mean that they
don't have a federal tax liability and
it doesn't mean that they do have a
federal tax liability but it's certainly
misleading and that's the only reason
why 1283 exists is just to
make sure that we're not misleading
granite staters but i could certainly
see you might want to have a a warning
label on the the voucher program saying
distribution warning distributions may
be taxable so thanks
okay i i've got a question
where's the the pell grants on the
federal level
have certain qualified expenses which
are tax-exempt i.e textbooks fees
tuition computer technology etc computer
technology is not actually deductible
well
people might be deducting i think a lot
of people are doing that now seeing
that's treated the same way as a
textbook for many people now so but
but
subtract that out of it then there's
other
aspects to that which are are
tax uh exempt uh
in relation to the pell grants now if
that happens for the
higher education why then would it not
occur for
k-12 yeah so um so thanks very much for
for the question and i'm trying to find
the irs bolton but it's called irs
bulletin 970.
and uh and it says tax benefits for
education i've got the 2020 uh verge
version right here publication 970 and
it goes through each of the um the the
things which are considered taxable or
non-taxable under under uh irs
by the irs
and
and it uh
it does talk about uh
education savings accounts so if we go
uh
and it says esa's at a glance uh what
are you are you talking to 529's no i'm
i'm no i'm not talking 529 so i'm
talking about education savings accounts
and
let's see and it's it's interesting here
because it does say that that certain um
expenses like qualified education
expenses generally these are expenses
required for the enrollment
or attendance
of the designated beneficiary at an
eligible educational institution so
eligible education institution
the expense
can be either qualified higher education
expenses or qualified elementary and
secondary education expenses and then
when you look at
qualified eligible institutions an
eligible institution an eligible
educational institution can be either an
eligible post-secondary school or an
eligible elementary or secondary school
so there's lots of things
the definition
of of uh of elementary or secondary
schools
and um and at least according to
publication
uh those would not be
um
tax deductible expenses and so so i
think there's there's a clear murkiness
to to what what can be deducted and what
can't be deducted and i just wouldn't
want um the program to be misleading um
of efa students and their families
that uh that these distributions are tax
deductible uh they might you know if we
had a state tax we could you could make
a deductible from new hampshire taxes
but we really don't have that
jurisdiction when it comes to federal
tax and this is just a transparency
thing
further further discussion
representatives
can you read that first section again
because my understanding of what you
said was it is for the things necessary
for
taking part in those programs and then
the second part was those programs and
wouldn't the things necessary be all
those things like computers and papers
and pencils and books and all that kind
of stuff
so i didn't get into into that you can
take a look at the pel section
on here which excludes certain materials
like computers
um uh but the i mean the whole bulletin
is
95 pages long
so
you know i'm and i'm not an expert on
the bulletin i just looked at the
the part that that talked about uh
education savings account and i think it
raised enough questions in my mind to uh
and and to to to a tax attorney's mind
um
that that said you know what you might
want to revisit this line in 194 f
and and just not mislead people i mean
taking leaving leaving it in doesn't
change anybody's so killing this bill
doesn't change anybody's tax liability
passing this bill doesn't change
anybody's tax liability um it's just a
transparency issue just try not to
mislead people um but but you know and
i'm not asking for everybody to weigh in
on this people can do whatever they want
uh on it and um
but i think it's pretty straightforward
thank you uh further discussion
representative porter
just
two a being a parental brag here but
my daughter attended
cornell on a national science foundation
grant
in graduate school she got her doctorate
in geochemistry just so that you know
that
and she did have to pay taxes on
that grant she had to figure out every
year how much taxes and set it aside so
when she did her federal taxes she had
the money
so just you know there's different rules
for different areas
and it's
it would be
unfortunate if someone thought that they
didn't know any taxes and then got
audited and find out they did afterwards
is not a pleasant
position to be in so
but i'm so proud of her
congratulations on cornell
she won't let me call her dr porter but
good job
uh further discussion
not seeing any uh madam clerk would you
house bill 1283 this is relative to
liability as taxable income of education
freedom accounts the motion on the table
is itl representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
yes representative lakers yes president
moffatt
yes representative hobson yes roseanne
ford
yes president saudi yes representative
nelson yes
rob
no president of waltz no
representative cornell no
representative tanner no
rep sam walner no
represent mullen no from sam woodcock
roseanne porter no
representative wall
oh no oh
i'm sorry it's lunchtime
chairman lad
yes okay
itl passes ten to nine okay
uh yeah it is lunchtime and i think
we're gonna take a break and get uh
lunch in us
um
an hour
okay so one o'clock we'll come back
yeah yeah and we're going to be
caucusing in here so
you can go upstairs in caucus or
wherever you go
if we can get through the list that we
have today
um i will i don't
want to have to schedule for
it what would if we had to come back
it'd be a result of the storm coming in
on friday
but that would not have to be posted all
we need is 24 hours when you have a
storm come in and so we would we would
have to meet if that storm comes we will
have to meet next week chances are if we
have to meet next week
it would have to be like the
monday or the friday i've got this this
annual trustee for the meeting for the
higher education in the middle of the
week here
and it's all at keene state
and so i won't be here and i know
there's several others to have plans for
tuesday
uh so it would have to be and i'm
wednesday thursday so it had to be the
friday or the monday
yes we do
we have a busy down unless we can pick
up some of the stuff and that's what
we're going to try to do but we also
have one on friday this week as well
yeah
woodcock i couldn't hear you and that's
great oh wait
all right settlers we've got some otps
would be quicker
yes yes okay let's go get lunch excuse
me chairman ladman just ask on 1283 will
there be a minority report and who is
doing it yes
11.52 yeah mary jane and i have a um
caucus for finance at 4 30 this
afternoon
you
i press the wrong button
there's two buttons on this bike
okay i'm opening the hearing now after
lunch on 13 55
and i recognize glenn cordelli
representative cordelia for a motion
thank you i would move uh itl on house
bill 1355.
do we have a second
recognized representative
hobson me all second thank you
uh representative cordelli you want to
speak on your motion
uh yes thank you um
my concern on this um
is that this uh
undermines the
efa rules that were uh just passed
friday by uh joe carr
the
[Music]
the rules went through a series of
modifications and discussions with joe
carr
and the final rules um include
the terms intentional and substantial
and have definitions for both
uh definition for
um intentional
um is uh willful and
uh knowledgeable
um and the definition for substantial is
250 dollars
so passing this
would
just undermine
all the work that was done and
on the final rules and require
new rules to be uh developed
where was it hobson anything to add
yeah absolutely um we do have an
amendment 1355
that
i think is is
is consistent with with what we what we
talked about during the hearing on this
bill it does take out the word
intentional which doesn't
mean the rules
have to change they can still leave that
definition in there but the law would
only require substantial misuse of efa
funds
to be reported to the attorney general
for investigation and um
and uh
i think i would i would support um
introducing the amendment and uh moving
forward with that well we can't
introduce the amendment until we lest
the itl fails
and for another motion anybody else
speak
you know we'll probably wait for the
chairman to return right yeah
um i think we got to keep going right
through it
we're here
we're all here no we're not at all no
right
the legislation currently
calls for
intentional and substantial misuse of
funds
to be reported to the attorney general's
office for investigation
the rules that were developed
by the department
with input from
jail car and others
left in those words
and defined intentional as knowingly and
willfully
so i think that passing this
legislation would undermine the rules
that were just
remember that
thank you mr chair uh representative
cordelli i'm not familiar with the
complete rules can you tell me if the
rule would require um
these cases to be referred to the
i believe that's in the original
legislation
isn't the original legislation the bill
was the the law that's before us
that says may not shall oh
so it doesn't require it and the
original legislation it's only in this
amendment that would or this bill that
would require i i believe it's also in
the contract between the department and
the scholarship organization is it in
the contract is a may or a shell i
believe it's a shell
is there a way to confirm that instead
of i believe
um i i will attempt to endeavor to do
that
okay
well that is going on
well you can do that and check on that
online when i recess
this for
and
i don't think you have to recess it
because yeah
yeah yeah no i mean just to move on to
the next bill
so for a few minutes
and we'll move on to
i didn't bring my glasses with me
1376 and i recognized representative
this is education freedom account
and
yeah and representative moffat
give a second
thank you
representative hobson you want to speak
i i i don't have an explanation for that
i'm sorry
you want to speak
sure if i might um
i think that there are several issues
with this
one
all
participants in the
efa program
with
disabilities um are not going to be um
placed by their parents in a uh private
uh facility
which
is
indicated here
um on lines four and five on a with the
there will be
parents who are providing for their
children
the bill was replaced with an amendment
we're dealing with it right we're
dealing with the uh bill as originally
in
installed now
as originally presented right i put the
amendment out during the hearing though
right
we can only be brought forward if it's
an otp do you remember replace the
builder in the hearing though that
doesn't matter
the amendment is is 0439h
representative cornell handed it out
during the hearing and spoke to it
during the hearing
and spoke to the amendment not to the
original bill during the hearing the
process still has to be uh to pass
introduce the amendment uh to pass the
amendment and then not to pass as
amended right so not disputing the
process right but i think in fairness
here um i hope representatives are
looking at the amendment because the
amendment
specifically is a is a technical
correction to make sure that it's
specifying the proper
code
for idea
and it's not about it's not about
whether or not students with
disabilities are going to facilities
it's about the fact that the efa program
is a parental placement under 20 usc
which is the idea code so just being in
an efa program is considered a parental
placement
and and that is absolutely fact in fact
that's in current law
and
yeah that's in current law right
the efa program is parental placement
under 20 usc
so it calls out the correct part of the
code
and and and makes it very clear
in the in both the bill actually in the
amendment
about what um what what parents and
students rights are under idea
i mean
mr chair
i'm sorry i am i am remembering now i
think that um
rep cornell am i am i right in that
your intention with this amendment was
that children or students who
participate
in education freedom accounts would
waive their special education
no
okay no
the intention is that parentally placed
students the parents will receive a
notice that if they are parentally
placing their students they waive their
right
yes mr chair i'm wondering this has
happened a couple of times and i'm
wondering if
the
itl motion might be withdrawn
so an otp motion can go forward so that
we can vote on the amendment
and if the amendment is voted down then
go to itl but i think it's only fair
because
representative cornell did bring in the
amendment
it addressed some major issues
and it's a really important thing for
parents to know right i sort of agree
but the point is was
hey good
[Laughter]
did somebody second the ito
yes
okay
here are we okay we couldn't we were
ready to take the vote on 1355 but
we couldn't because you weren't here so
i moved on to 1376 and we're issuing
that now because
um
representative
cornell
put it spoke on the amendment
on that and so we did an itl but should
it be an otp with the amendment then if
that fails we can idl so
back and i see your notes here rick so i
don't know what they meant so
that's that good cursing so look
so
and then it says exactly what
parents
and students what their rights would be
underlined yeah
uh
i mean
this is this is more than housekeeping
it doesn't change the policy
get lunch um the table here and and
it is my fault i was not on the ball i
apologize
um if i might mr chairman yes go ahead
um i i
also object to the word wave of their
rights
but they do
if i could
waving means
something different to me
they are no longer covered in id
under ie dea
but at any point in time
they can go back to their public school
and be covered by idea
that's correct yeah right so that's
right
right and so i i i do not think the term
wave um is is proper in this case as to
they're not waving their rights they're
just not
no longer covered right because they can
go back at any point
isn't that what wave means
i'm i recognize that i'm not
going to have these rights while i'm
here at this school
i'm waving them while i'm here at this
school
um
i'm sorry it means something different
we had this argument
four or five years ago when we
had a
efa
bill for special needs children
um and this was the subject of quite a
i have some additional information first
on the
last bill is that the contract says
shall so that was a question does it say
shall or may that's the last bill
it says shall but
as far as this efas are not always
parental placements and that was that's
the information i just got and that the
rules themselves clarify that
so the so
we're assuming where this is stating
that it is and apparently it's not
yes uh represent tanner so
uh representative lucas when you when
you said not all students are a
placement
do you mean
whether they have a disability or not
i mean who are all the students
that you're talking about
the scholarship organization is
listening to her are hearing and trying
to answer questions for us when they
come up
and so her response is efa is not always
a parental placement
i'm not sure
all i have is the information i just got
sent
i don't get that
and she said the rules clarify that
so i mean if i could i have the rules in
front of me
um
participation in the efa program is a
parental placement under 20 usc 1412
individuals with disabilities education
act if a child with a disability is
enrolled in a non-public school
a child with a disability participating
in an efa program and enrolled in a
public school is covered under 194 f2
2d
and is entitled to fape
parentally placed students with
disabilities shall not be entitled to
faith in connection with their
enrollment by their parents in a private
school
so i
everybody in agreement with what you
just said
no because the law here the bill that
we're looking at says in a public or
private elementary a secondary school
is a
a parental placement except
if they're in a public school they're
not a parental placement
yeah right i i believe that there was
a mis
statement mischaracterization in the
original legislation
that is repeated in this legislation but
uh starting from the top participation
in the efa program is a parental
placement under 20 usc 1412 idea
if a child is with a disability is
enrolled in a non-public school
a child with a disability participating
in an efa program and enrolled in a
public school
which is possible
f colon 2 roman 2 d is not a parental
placement under idea
though parentally placed in a private
school with disabilities shall not be
entitled to faith in connection with
their enrollment by their parents in a
private school
in accordance with 34 or fcr et cetera
while participating in the state funded
efa program
the school district in which the child
with a disability participating in in an
efa program is enrolled in a public
school under 194 is responsible for
provision of faith
so
it in this in the rules it's also
covering um which is not covered here um
the instance where a
efa student could be placed
in an out of district
public school
and it's making the distinction that
they are still covered by fape under
that under um and under idea
whereas if they are placed in a private
school a non-public school
they are no longer covered by um
by idea
and i much prefer non-covered to wave
because wave means give up your rights
and you're not you still retain the
rights but you don't have them in this
case it is too different
wave means to defer by definition it
doesn't say give up wave means defer
it's not in that
mr chair it's not i don't see the word
wave in the amendment
was what
represent porter
thank you mr chair so under the rules
i think the
the and if i'm understanding the amended
bill
the intent is to make sure parents
understand
that they may not
will not be eligible
for special ed services under certain
conditions
if they have an efa
in the rules representative cordelli
that you just read
is there anything in the rules
that requires
notification to the parent that they may
be
giving giving up their
rights to
special ed services while they are
participating in the program
under a section called the application
shall contain the following and what i
read was
read it again
participation in the efa program is
in a is a parental placement under 20
usc 1412 idea if a child with a
disability is enrolled in a non-public
school
a child with a disability participating
in an efa program and enrolled in a
public school under
194 f2
roman d2 is not a parental placement
under idea
and shall be entitled to fate
and then it basically including the same
where is that placed
on the application to be part of an efa
program
um wait when a parent is obsessed
it's under section
805 of the rules application and
enrollment
and this is under 805
805.01
application development agreement and
notification requirements
so that's stated on the application that
the parent is filling out
to enroll their child in a program
representative
let's let's go to representative cornell
right now the the intent of this was was
simply to make parents aware that they
may be giving up their rights or that
they are giving their our rights to a
special education under idea if they
parentally place a child in private
education and we want parents to know
what they are signing up for so that
they can make the best decisions before
they place their child
in a placement and then find out that
they're not going to i get that so is it
possible that this wording that's in
this zero four three nine h amendment
could be reworked a little bit at the
bottom to
adjust to some of that what i don't mind
the word wave because they are waving
that right while they are in the
placement
yeah but we could do that
i can i can do it yeah yeah there are
some issues between public and privates
here
okay there's a little difference there
and that's what we you might want to
work on i think we can arrive at that
common ground
would you do that between the three of
you please here
i also can i ask a question sure this is
an exact session not a hearing and i i
thought when we wanted the public to
give us some information or someone we
we asked for it
and
rough laker seems to be getting
information
constantly
because i've asked for it
because when people say i don't know the
answer to that
then i ask so that i can reply so that
we can have the answer so if you say if
somebody asks the question and the
answer is i don't know the answer to
that then i've been asking and you even
asked specifically for the answer to one
of those and i asked and got the answer
i i've just never seen the the issue
that you address it would be very
relevant if we were conducting a hearing
um i've been at hearings with uh
northern pass
and representative rappaport and i were
sitting there and listening to and
seeing
questions being delivered to the
committee hearing the bill
from the audience in rep hall
which was
not really the way it should work you if
you in repsol if you're there at a
hearing you should stand up and testify
but then you shouldn't have the ability
to act like a person sitting on that
committee by delivering questions for a
committee member to ask a person who's
testifying that's not the way it works
but in an executive session we have
folks here now where we're using our
computers we can go check any i i think
i see a lot of us doing that and using
the phone is you know pretty similar
mr chair yeah so just getting back to
business here on 439 h
um if an amendment was to come forward
that addressed line 13
that took out the words that such
students possess and wave
i i think it's already covered in the
final rules so i would still be in favor
because it's on the application
well let's just make sure that that i
mean this is an important thing this is
like a warning label
um
if we just if if the if the new language
in the amendment read
starting on line 11 the scholarship
organization shall provide parents of
students with disabilities who are not
enrolled
in a pri who are not enrolled in a
private elementary or secondary school
of an explanation of rights under idea
you took out wave
what's that yeah took out that such
possess and wave
took out the first what about on line 10
there's nothing changed online possess
and wave
that was that's oh possess n
waves um because he doesn't like wave
suspend
you could work on it
because we can't act on anything right
now
but i have been notified that yes it is
on the application so yes the parents
are getting that so your intent of the
thank you miss chair
um i'm not sure that it is our job as
legislators to be making i'm hearing you
know the intent of this this measure is
to is to quote make parents aware or
represent lino just said uh use the term
warning label is it our job to put
warning labels on statutes i think
there's a need for
personal responsibility on the part of
parents and i i think there's some good
points about parents need to know what
they're getting into what they may be
losing
but i just i'm trying to get my head
around us putting warning labels on
legislation
sorry and she also said they already
updated the second handbook to contain
the required notice yesterday so it's
representative
thank you um i just want to respond to
the last comment and that is you know i
started my career litigating cases
special ed cases all over the country in
all 50 states i can assure you and the
laws have gotten done nothing but get
more complicated since then i can assure
you most parents of special ed kids are
very confused by what's before them what
their rights are what what they aren't
which the best approach for their kids
it's just overwhelming for them and i
think anything we can do that helps
clarify for them what they're doing what
they're waving what they're getting you
know both sides with what they're giving
up and what they're getting for their
child
is something that we should be doing it
is our responsibility to make it clear
to those parents and yes there should be
some parental responsibility but i can
assure you every parent of a special ed
student i have ever seen is out there
struggling to understand it struggling
to find the best for their child and
just trying to sort it out and it's
really complicated it's really hard and
that's why i would support something
like this if we get the wording right
because i think we owe that to the
parents
if if i may mr chair
yeah thank you i i agree i i'm sure that
it's daunting and it's very complicated
and it gets emotional my point my
question is with all the resources that
are out there uh to provide guidance to
parents in areas like this i'm just
questioning is is it our job to put it
into this big thick yellow book a new
law
uh with a warning label to make parents
or i agree and i and i i think they
deserve counsel and help and i think
it's out there in many places other than
us making a law
ma'am respond
yes go ahead and then uh represent court
cordelia and then refsemon
i think
that's part of our role is to try and
make this easier for them and i have no
problem with putting them into the rsas
i have no problem with putting them in
statute that this is just one more thing
we're going to help them because
they are reading this stuff and they are
not understanding it try as they might
they're not lawyers they're not
educators they are not understanding it
and again anything we can do to make it
easier for them so they understand the
implications of what they're doing i do
think that is our responsibility and i
have no problem i mean we're talking
about one more sentence in the rsas i
mean
you know we're talking about a huge
chapter that's another story we're
groups on cordelia
thank you um i would just
webpage under the scholarship fund for
education freedom accounts
and in this section there is a parent
parent handbook frequently asked
questions provider handbook education
provider sign up list of providers
csf policies and a withdrawal form from
and
you know if anyone's interested
this list of providers is five pages
long
what to say about special rights under
ida
um i i
am not sure i haven't looked
that um
and um in addition there's a link to the
class wallet marketplace
for um view for providers integrated
representative mullen thank you mr chair
um i understand that this information
may be on the application form and that
parents who are
very interested in the efa program are
likely to be the people that are looking
at that application because they want to
get involved
my concern is with parents that are
exploring
the program sort of from uh
the
the bottom up if you will not knowing
anything about the program because i can
tell you
the ed 800 rules do not appear on the
doe website under ed 800. i have been
searching for efa information on and off
for the past year
and have inquired many times about why
the rules were in ed 300 and when they
were and i was told they were going to
be transferred to at 800 why they
weren't in at 800 and they're not in
eight eight ed 800 does not appear on
the doe website today so the idea
representative moffat to get back to
your point that this information is so
easily and readily available
i haven't been able to find easy answers
to the questions so again anything we
can do to assist parents at
knowing what the what the rules and rags
um the rules couldn't have been up
earlier because they just got passed on
friday
and they just went up on monday so
you might want to look again
because because uh yeah the preliminary
and temporary rules were
yeah
but at any but at any rate
it is now the information that's in this
as as uh representative cordelli just
was naming the various sections there is
the parents handbook
and it is now in there it went in
yesterday
the information that you guys are
looking for here is in the parents
handbook it went in yesterday it's in
rules it's on the application and it's
now in the parents handbook so it's
there
further discussion
okay i see i still like to see amending
language come forward
so we're not going to take action on
this at this time and i'm not going to
have any more discussion on this bill
there's a motion on the floor
yeah and we don't have to act on that
motion until i'm ready to act on that
motion i can wait that can wait that is
i've done that many a time here
previously
very good
ralph and what we did on 11 14.
yeah
okay so where did where did i miss
something here 11 14.
okay so uh
okay
and the motion was what itl
itl made by
represent cordelli
and second by represent hobson
okay and it's about what 13 requiring
the scholarship organization to refer
suspected cases of fraud oh miss okay
misuse of fraud in
okay
so
are we ready for the vote on that
if i could just yeah one one additional
within five days suspected suspected
cases of intentional and substantial
misuse of ea funds shall be reported by
the scholarship
organization the department the board
the attorney general and for cases
exceeding the amount
of a class b felony law
local law or state law
that agency goes farther than the bill
itself right here yeah
okay
okay so any further discussion
madam clerk would you please call the
roll
1355.
house bill 1355 requiring the
scholarship organization to refer
suspected cases of misuse of funds or
fraud in the education freedom account
program to the attorney general the
motion on the table is ito
representative cordelli
yes representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative lakis yes represent
moffat
yes representative hopson
yes
representative ford
yes representative yes
sam nelson yes
representative luno no
roseanne waltz no
representative cornell no representative
tanner no
representative walder no representative
no from sam woodcock no
represent porter
representative hall no
and chairman ladd yes
so the itl carries ten to nine
okay we're going down to sixteen uh uh
who would be doing that
okay
1637 requiring parents of people a
public school students to submit a
survey when electing an education
freedom account
uh
representative uh
litchfield
are you ready for that or do you want
someone else to do it i am i make the
motion ito
and reps and hops
thank you uh do you care to speak on
that
yes
um
the prime sponsor spoke to this actually
the day that that he gave testimony he
himself had stated i quote maybe this
bill is not ready for prime time
some of the concerns within this bill
regarding the survey is it does not
state anonymous
parents may not be comfortable filling
out the survey especially if they have
other children currently in the district
that they have left
there were concerns with this bill that
it states this survey is conditional
upon receiving efa funds
and finally the children's scholarship
fund
the representative mentioned that they
already do this and it is anonymous and
go ahead i'll make an additional comment
that um
currently the children's scholarship
fund is collecting that information and
as written this bill is a condition of
enrollment
as pointed out by matt sotherton
from children's scholarship fund is
there a further discussion from the
committee on this bill the motion was
not seeing any madam clerk would you
yes regarding house bill 1637
requiring parents of public school
students to submit a survey when
electing an education freedom account
the motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative lakis yes
represent moffitt
yes
represent hobson yes representative ford
yes president
yes representative nelson yes
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
represent cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
wallner yes
i'm sam mullen yes
represent woodcock
representative porter
represent paul yes
and chairman ladd yes so the motion of
any objections to consent
please
good we got one
okay uh
hb 1649 is next
relative to unique pupil identification
for pupils in the education freedom
account program
represent cordelia recognized for a
motion
do we have a second
mr chair i'd like to second that motion
okay
okay we we have a motion on the table
for 1649
it's itl the motion was made by
representative cordelli
and second by represent tanner
represent cordelia would you like to
speak to your motion
thank you
i believe we passed
a similar bill
16 20 or something along those lines
most of that is duplicated in this bill
i think the one new paragraph in this
bill
at the bottom uh contains some things
that might be
difficult for the scholarship
organization because it would require
state
student level data system which they do
representative tanner do you have
anything to add please yes the other
and uh yes i think uh
it was we covered it with
attorney fenton on the other one
what was needed thank you thank you is
there any further discussion from
committee members
not seeing any any uh
madam clerk
this is house bill 1649 relative to
unique people identification for pupils
in the education freedom account program
the emotion on the table is itl
representative cordelli
yes representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
yes
representative hobson yes
representative ford
yes representative sodie yes i'm sam
nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz
yes
represent cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
wildner yes
or sam mullen yes represent woodcock
represent porter
representative paul yes and chairman
ladd yes
the motion of itl pass is 19 to zero
any problems with consent
not seeing any great uh we'll put that
one on consent
an act requiring the department of
education to administer the education
okay
representative moffat do you have a
motion
i do miss chair i would move my tl on
this
and represent lakers right second thank
you very much
uh represent moffitt would you like to
speak to your motion
uh sure mr briefly uh this bill changes
the administration of the efa program
from the scholarship organizations to
the to doe
and it's to me it seems to presuppose
that doe would be the better
administrator
uh and again as the efa program is in
its first year
the first part of its first year i think
it's too early to pass judgment
on on the efficacy
of the scholarship organization's
program management
and further the the bill's fiscal note
uh cited and indeterminate
expense for doe to assume such
management of the efa program so
uh the and doe presently does not have
the staff to administer the efa program
so a measure such as this would make
more sense to consider
later on after after at least a year
of uh efa administration by the
scholarship organization
thank you very much uh
the
maker of the second is there any uh
discussion on this
just that i have in my notes that
while the maximum that can be spent
um for administering it is 10
by the
scholarship organization
i have greater than 12 and a half
percent
for
administrators for public school
districts just as a comparison so
thank you representative porter
so i'm sure this is a question that
there are going to be people happy to
answer for me
i'm seeming to remember way back when we
first passed on the
education tax credit program
but i don't remember how the scholarship
granting organization was chosen
was there a bidding
where
did we send out bids and ask for
applications and then choose one
and is that the same organization i
think is the same organization
that's dealing with the efa accounts so
i'm sure that representative cordelli is
going to be very happy to answer that
for me okay representative cordelia can
you
answer the question whether or not i i
would be delighted
um
my uh
recollection and understanding is that
there is an application process
through the department of revenue
administration for any organization that
wants to
and is the only applicant the one that's
there
there is a second
um
but i believe that um that program is
also managed by the csf for them
and if i could um just in relation to
the efa program um the rules clarify the
intent of the bill and that there can be
multiple scholarship organizations
and that
to get the program up and running since
this program excuse me this csf was in
operation already with this with the tax
credit scholarship program uh there was
a sole source contract with them but the
uh uh intent is to um uh provide for
so if i'm understanding you correctly
it's possible that other
scholarship granting organizations might
step forward as wanting to administer or
partially administer that program
many of the suggestions that we've made
concerning
putting into
statute requirements like having
background checks and
and things that are on applications and
those kinds of things we've gotten the
answer that's all spelled out in the
contract
so if another organization was going to
come forward would that contract that
they have be the same kind of contract
that we have i would expect
but there's no guarantee i i don't know
i haven't talked to the department about
that but um
maybe you have some ideas for future
plans
no thank you i just wanted to know to
make sure that we that we opened it up
to people other than just this one
organization that seems
now to be the one that we're
contracted with in deferring to when
rules and regulations
are concerned
thank you further discussion from the
committee representative tanner
thank you um
i think this is an important bill i i
think that the writing is kind of on the
wall with
the unique
pupil identifier number
the reason i put my bill in and
obviously uh it came from representative
cordelia almost at the same time was
recognition that the department of
education had to have some way to track
these uh
these kids to find out
um you know where they're going
what's happening when they when they
leave the program when they age out of
the program
so and we talked about uh background
checks and the background checks are
going to have to go through the
department of education
the scholarship organization as much as
we're saying you know this is a new
program this is a program that's that's
developed in a bunch of other states in
the in the united states it's not unique
to new hampshire although there are
parts of it that are unique to it and
the scholarship organization is not
a new organization just a startup in new
hampshire it's a national organization
with headquarters in new york city so uh
that and the scholarship organization
runs
a lot of programs in the other states as
well
so and then we heard this morning
actually that they had you know it isn't
just the two people on the scholarship
organization in new hampshire that the
national scholarship organization has
quite quite a deep resource of
information and
and ability to
print you know to advertise to get
materials whatever
so um i think the
the overriding thing is that
we've got a department of education um
they
obviously every time we ask for things
they don't have enough staff
and we're a policy organizat committee
not the finance committee if if they
need more finances they need more people
the department of education needs to go
before finance that's not
shouldn't be i think our issue our issue
is
there should be some
centralized area and as i said this
unique pupil identifier and the fact
that we're looking at how to set up
background checks and that sort of thing
are all have to go through the
department of education
and so if they have to go through there
it makes sense to me that
some that the administration for this
program that there should be a part in
the doe that's administration of this
program and that's why
i would vote
against the itl thanks
thank you are there any for represent
hobson
i'm sorry i just would like to ask a
clarifying question it seems to me that
we've had plenty of bills go through
looking for a position at the doe to
help administer the efa
uh program is
did we in fact take that vote already i
have not seen the rules
that came out of jail car so i don't
that's still in process then
it passed
further discussion representative
woodcock then representative lucas
thank you chairman
i'm surprised this is
a pretty bipartisan bill but i'm
surprised that we would take a
program that is
uh
going to continue to increase i would
say at least in the short term uh and we
know we're
paying a 10
fee
to a private organization as
representative porter alluded uh
on on marginal numbers that means right
now it's 720 000 of paying them
the paper
and we have the opportunity for
to bring this back in house for a lot
less than 720 000
and then continue to have oversight on
that
as we go on now i just think it makes a
lot of taxpayer sense in this case the
transparency
and with doe going to have the
opportunity multiple times and needs
some data from them and vice versa
well we're housing criminal background
checks for how the other important
aspects of education in youngstown new
hampshire and which this is i mean yeah
if you have 10 percent you have 1800
kids in this program already climbing
which is terrific for some respects but
it should be handled inside by our
people not by a small organization in
new york city just making seven hundred
twenty thousand dollars a start you give
it away annually giving it away
thank you further discussion
representative hobson
sorry just um pivoting on um rep
woodcock's
idea or comments uh wouldn't we pay
don't other agencies use contractors and
is ten percent uh common or
anyone who might have an answer i would
thank you for the real positive note
there the senior member i hope that
doesn't mean more white hair or less i'm
out of the republican side okay thank
you
um we do contract a number of services
over there professional development by
way of essa is contracted out
and that's a very important aspect of
education here getting our staff all
trained in certain topics so yeah
contracting services to third parties is
very typical throughout all the states
follow up i would concur with you as a
senior member i wouldn't wouldn't try to
change that but that being said that
doesn't negate the fact that this this
contract of 72 7 what 707
200 000 70 to 720 000
or more rounded off 800 yeah yeah and a
thousand and climbing um can be done
in-house and when we have the control of
it um the essa grants or the p
professional development grants you're
bringing in resource people this is
something that's not this is not
uh you know ultra
difficult this this is a a
organizational piece you have you have
every expert you can possibly think of
in doe right there on your resource this
is just in 10 years there's seven
million dollars of fees you paid for no
reason they have it right there it's not
going to cost and they have the control
that's all i just unless you're just not
going to cost money it's going to cost
money how you do it i just think it's
better to have it in-house so we can
control it ourselves and have all the
data we need
thank you thank you uh representative
cordelli uh thank you uh i just point
out in terms of startup costs um
the class wallet system that is used
to
track uh expenses
is a very expensive
piece of software and is now being used
by anyone who wants to develop
such a program
arizona
the first education savings account
state
had problems
off the bat for the pers first six years
or so
because they were trying to do a paper
system not an automated system and it
was a reimbursement system to the
to the families
and they did have some
problems that were found
in audits
due to the fact and they are now moving
to
implement the class wallet system so
anyone
implementing such a program such as
children's scholarship fund that has
done this
is now contracting with class wallet or
a similar system because you need that
electronic capability to track those
expenses and make sure the
expenses that are submitted
are valid even though it then goes
through a manual check in addition to
that thank you representative moffitt
thank you mr chair uh represent woodcut
really get my attention um
extrapolating that's 800 000 out to 7
million over time i think that's a very
good point it gets my attention but i i
do need to say
that as i said my
initial remarks the program is is in its
infancy and i note that the effective
date is july
for us 2022 that's almost here i mean
we're almost in the march and it's this
bill's still in committee
so i i
i i think it would be good for us to
especially if the cfa position ends up
with doe i think that's something we
should look at
but this particular bill
is just not going to work uh in the
short term before uh
july 1st 2022.
yeah representative lucas
and then representative woodcock
since when has it been cheaper you guys
were talking about money cheaper for a
government to do something than a
private organization
and there are five staff people
currently in new hampshire to deal with
this plus the wallet plus other things
it i mean they're doing well to keep the
money down to what they're keeping it
down to
and
if you wanted i mean the department of
education would have to hire at least
those five people
plus
and i'd my understanding is they don't
the d.o.e
representative what represent woodcock
well i'm sure there's a lot of things we
passed and the idea we doesn't want
this happens on a regular basis or
things they do want um but that being
said if i recall on representative
cordelia's comment when when this
program first came in
uh they weren't talking wallet
they were talking when we first started
their type of paper i agree 100 uh
glenn that that that wallet is the way
to go or some some facts will be thereof
um and it took arizona six years to
figure out but when we started that they
were still talking paper but that's but
that did not negate the fact that no
matter what
i t system that dlt would use
it'll be our system and i understand
it's gonna be costly any other program
is on the computer today but it's still
our money i control our taxes and i i
can't help but think the possible future
of this program and the connections with
doe right there all the stuff the data
they can get it'll be perfect the
transparency everything in the end is
going to cost a whole lot less that's
all it's not going to change the program
i'm not trying to wipe out the program
we're trying to say bring if you wanted
an ef a program here let's run it our
way
thank you thank you further discussion
well you can take it first to
legislative oversight and then
they can do it
yeah
okay uh
not see any further hands on this one we
will
call the the issue madam clerk
this is regarding house bill 1669
requiring the doe to administer the
education freedom account program the
motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli
yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative lacus
yes
represent moffat
representative hobson yes
representative ford yes
representative sodi yes
representative nelson
representative luno no
representative waltz no
representative cornell no from tanner no
representative wallner
no sorry
representative
no
representative woodcock
representative porter no
representative
no
and chairman ladd yes
is mr woodcock going to do the minority
report
okay
nice thing about this they're all
sequential and you don't have to turn
any pages
relative to funds of the education
freedom account program after
termination of a student's participation
and responsibilities of the scholarship
organization
and i look to represent hobson for a
motion
this time representative hobson is
prepared i make a motion to itl
and representative
i'm prepared to second that thank you
represent hobson do you have any uh
remarks
motion this bill to itl
the withdrawal process has been
clarified in rules
we also have an oversight committee for
education freedom accounts
and
as was stated earlier we are forwarding
legislation to provide a the doe with
some administrative help it at the doe
so i don't believe that this legislation
is necessary
further discussion from the second
uh
which she said yes
okay
from the committee any further yes
representative luno mr chair so
based on um
discussion uh that happened during the
uh
during the bill's introduction and
hearing
uh i did prepare we did prepare an
amendment uh to 1670 that addressed the
chair's concern on page two at line 14
to change five business days to ten
business days
um uh
the um the
you know i
do not believe the uh the rules
go as far as um
1670 uh
as amended
uh do in um
in
managing the uh the requirements of the
program following termination
and um
and like i say the the
it's very important at least
at least with respect to uh the chair's
suggestion to move um
from as quickly as possible to within 10
business days for notification of an uh
of that an education service provider is
no longer eligible to receive uh funds
we feel is that uh that's pretty
important and um and and as as is the
entire bill so i would
be happy to
give the chair a copy of the amendment
and uh
should should the chair feel that the
amendment is worth considering
uh for the whole committee i've got
copies for everybody but
that's um i think i've seen do you have
a copy for the clerk i do yeah
we'll just pass it around
so basically this changes that one from
so is there any further discussion on on
not seeing any um
if i yes i would just point in in rules
it
uh
because everybody have a copy of this
so
is there any further discussion on the
bill 1670
not seeing any uh madam clerk would you
house bill 1670 relative to funds of the
education freedom account program after
termination of a student's participation
and responsibilities of the scholarship
organization the motion on the table is
itl
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative bone yes
representative lancas yes represent
moffat
yes represent hobson
represent ford
yes represent
yes representative nelson
representative luno no
oops
representative waltz no
representative cornell no president of
tanner
no
from sam walner no
or sam mullen
no
sam woodcock no
where's that porter
or said hall no and chairman ladd yes
representative ladd
over here
could i just um
give the committee some information
about
uh withdrawal from the program that they
might be able to use
going just very quickly there is a
oh just hold on a second
um
who's going to be doing the minority
report on this
okay
otp
okay you're not gonna know tpa okay otp
yeah that's what it should be well
just just put it in the folder and uh
we never acted upon it so it's like it
never existed
um
representative hobson
i just found out some information and i
just thought the committee would want to
know there is a withdrawal form
that people fill out when they're going
to exit the program i can forward a copy
to anybody who wants it also
if the account has been open for more
than a year the family is welcome to
spend down that money or they can
forfeit it and it'll go back to the
yes
so just uh just a question of that the
family is welcome to spend down that
okay well
just welcome the just the phrase welcome
to spend down that money sounds like it
sounds like um i can use it to
put in a down payment on a used tesla
which i'm sure some of these vouchers
are being used okay mr luno
that's not where i was going or maybe a
uh a porsche can at pan am
or maybe just dog food huh
okay
uh
hey well
okay hb 1672
relative
relative to misuse of education freedom
account funds
1672.
you're recognized for a motion
i move ito
okay
and represent cordelia
do you want to second it
uh represent lucas would you uh like to
speak to your motion i sure would thank
you you're welcome this bill has a
plethora of problems
um i won't find everyone
but let's see
uh the termination of the efa and the
transfer of any remaining funds back to
the education trust fund
that doesn't allow for current
transactions as we spoke about before
some of these things take a while to
order
and if the parent is already on the hook
for it
and it is coming but not arrived yet
that money needs and and
that money needs to be used to cover
that
um
the whole section four
has already been covered by the rules
and approved by joe carr
[Music]
the on d a parent or efa student may
appeal the scholarship organization's
decision to deny eligibility for the a
program to the an exchange to state
board of education
i don't know why it's going to the state
board of education because the doe
is
going to have hopefully a coordinator
that would deal with that
similarly down on line 15
in b
why not the doe coordinator
why are we taking it away from the
department and giving it to the state
and then taking out this whole section
putting it on
the doe
so the department shall adopt rules
which they have done
but then all these other things with ha
which have to do with the day-to-day
running of the program
should not the
people who are doing the day-to-day
running be the ones that work on that
that's the policies and procedures for
doing their job
and then
ensuring an appropriate use and over
rigorous oversight of all funds well the
scholarship organization is already
doing that but
the whole thing
has an oversight committee that's
already
you know the efa oversight committee
that's already doing that and that has
an oversight committee because we're
already oversighted and oversighted
at any rate so that's just some of them
but that'll do
thank you very much are there is there
represent luna
thank you very much mr chair um so what
we uh what we just heard um um omits a
whole lot of things and uh and
particularly where it where um uh where
we heard about the um uh use of the uh
deferral to the state board of education
for appeals that's what the state board
of education does as a matter of fact so
um so uh so i think i think
when you take a look at 1672 and you
take a look at
the first
three sections
which improve the integrity of the
program and you take a look at section
four
which improves the accountability pro of
the of the program uh by specifically
eliminating so this hasn't been covered
in rules this eliminates the um the word
intentional and does not put the
scholarship organization in the
untenable position of making some sort
of determination about what is being
being done willfully and
um and knowingly to defraud the
taxpayers of the state of new hampshire
so by taking out the word intentional it
take it puts takes the scholarship
organization out of that impossible
position
and um
and then finally uh which um which the
representative made the motion to kill
this bill
um talked about the importance of the
or
or the lack of importance for the
department to be involved in setting
rules that ensure the appropriate use
and rigorous oversight of all funds
expended under the program so that's all
taxpayer money expended out of the
program including the 10 percent of
taxpayer money that gets creamed right
off the top and retained within the
scholarship organization a cost that's
now approaching a million dollars and
it's probably on its way to 10 times
that once um once all private and
homeschool kids
jump into
this program so i think there's a lot
more oversight that that needs to be
done in order to protect
taxpayer money and
and
and really serve the integrity of this
program otherwise i don't think this
program is going to last very long thank
you
thank you very much is is there any uh
further discussion on the on the bill
not seeing any uh madam clerk would you
please call the rule
yes house bill 1672 relative to misuse
of education freedom accounts the motion
on the table is itl
representative cordelli
yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative blakes yes
yes representative hobson yes represent
ford
yes representative sodi yes i'm sam
nelson
representative luno
no representative
no or sam cornell no
or sam tanner no represent walnut no
representative mullen no
representative woodcock
representative porter
rosette hall no
and chairman ladd yes
so the emotion of itl carries ten to
nine
okay um
i'll be doing the minority of ought to
pass
okay
see we're going to get through this
today yeah we're going to get through it
quickly here
uh hb 1678
relative to the administration of the
education freedom accounts program
excuse me mr chair yeah i'm sorry before
we move on on house bill 1672 um is
representative luna looking for me to
put a motion of otp or otpa
just otp
okay once again we're moving into hb
relative to the administration of the
yeah i'm not going to speak to it but
uh yes uh house bill 1678 uh call upon
chairman ladd for a motion i'll make a
motion of itl
is there a second
uh
discussion no i'll pass on discussion
just let it go to the committee
discussion okay
likewise representative lakers
oh i was just gonna say this was already
taken care of in rules
bill's hoping for a discussion from the
committee
any discussion
hb 1678 relative to the administration
of the education freedom accounts
program the motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli
yes representative blitchfield is yes
representative boehm yes representative
blankist yes roxanne moffitt yes
represent hobson yes represent ford
yes
representative sony yes representative
nelson yes
representative bluno yes
representative waltz yes
representative cornell
yes
representative tanner yes
representative wallner yes
from sam mullen
yes represent woodcock
represent porter
representative hall yes
and chairman ladd yes
so the motion of itl carries 19 to zero
any problems with consent thank you
repealing the education freedom accounts
program
representative cordell you're recognized
for a motion uh thank you um probably
won't come as any great surprise i move
itl
second okay we have a second mate and
representative cordelli has made the
motion itl any further discussion from
the maker of the motion
uh just that
the program has gotten off to a very
successful start over eighteen hundred
kids uh now
um
the education option that needs meets
we'll see how the program goes in the
future and the number of
children applying but
i think the uh
the deployment of the system
um and getting it up and running in the
timely fashion that we did has drawn the
attention of
states around the nation um and i know
west virginia that passed a bill at the
same time
won't be getting their
system up and running until next
november so we had great discussions
with them at a conference that a number
of us attended and everyone is uh
looking to
model the uh
success and the efficiency of our
program
thank you representative saudi do you
have anything to add to that
uh
i just can't see pulling the rug out
from out from under the 1800 students
uh especially uh for the price that
we're getting at at 25 cents on the
dollar
a great uh example of the free market at
work i only wish we could
do a little bit more of that
thank you any further discussion from
the committee
mr chair yes
so thank you very much um i really
questioned 25 cents on the dollar
because for the vast majority of the
1800 students and we'll get we'll get a
detailed breakdown i'm sure very soon
from the um from the uh the contracting
uh organization at least according to
mr southington
um that that that these are students
that weren't costing the state anything
so so it's it's 25 cents on the zero
that that they were currently causing
morally obligated
don't go there right now
respond later so so i think you know as
as as information does come out
about the adoption rate of the um of
into the program participation into the
program we'll get a real understanding
of what the cost is to new hampshire
taxpayers and what sort of opportunities
this program is really um opening up for
students who were already in private
schools already being home schooled so
um
so but what i really want to go with
this is um is this program
this voucher program is already dying
from a thousand cuts and they're
self-inflicted wounds
and the bills that we've rejected over
the last couple weeks including many
today
uh were specifically designed to uh to
to
remedy those those cuts
the the
the first one and possibly the biggest
one
was was rejected on the floor of the
house last week which would have held
the program to be responsible to
budgeted amounts
and uh and this is this is frankly
something that is is hemorrhaging state
dollars where no state dollars were
being spent uh in the past the budget
was 129 000
and now it's if it's 1800 students i'm
sure we're probably over 9 million
dollars
coming out of state funds for uh for
students that were not costing
the state anything
and um and for students who were
were not costing local taxpayers
anything so it hasn't provided any
savings at uh at either level um
that bill was rejected on the floor of
the house last week
and uh and just today
oh and i should say that
there was an amendment to that bill that
would have provided consideration for
students already in the program so so
that we're not so cold-hearted that
we're throwing people out or making
people repay money it would it would
would hold the program to uh to the
actual cost for the these first two
years in the biennium and then to
budgeted costs in future use and put the
department in a position where it needs
to justify their budget before the
finance committee
so uh just today
we rejected criminal background checks
okay
there's uh and we even heard we even
heard a representative around this table
saying student safety is a parent's
responsibility no criminal background
checks it's the responsibility of the
parents to make sure
that uh that that's uh that that's in
place so um that was rejected today the
notice of parents that that the rights
for children with disabilities under
idea
just know what you have and know what
you don't have didn't actually change
the policy at all other than a
notification requirement other than a
warning sticker
and um and nope we're not going to do
that so uh so you know you find out as
you as you enter the program maybe you
didn't know and uh and and we'll see
what uh we'll see what happens good luck
parents and also good luck on the tax
liability so
the law says and probably the rules say
hey guess what these uh distributions
from the state directed at the parents
uh request are not subject to federal
tax lab actually the law says not
subject to tax liability but in new
hampshire our tax liability our income
tax liability is a federal uh income tax
liability so um again no policy change
other than just being truthful
with people who are looking at the
program
and knowing what they're getting into
but nope that's been been rejected um uh
the fraud prevention and i agree that
the rules improve upon where the
temporary rules were and uh and improve
upon where the where the the the law
says as far as fraud must be reported to
uh to either state or local officials
for investigation but it holds the
scholarship organization to such an
incredible standard to determine
what is what is what is willful and
knowledgeable
um uh
in terms of intent to defraud the state
of new hampshire i have no idea how a
scholarship organization is going to be
able to meet that high threshold that
really is up to uh to law enforcement
officials and the attorney general's
office
so um
so and then and then just a couple more
things we also rejected today a bill
that would have put a little bit of
accountability in terms of student
outcomes let's make sure taxpayers know
how well students that are taking
vouchers are doing we're being told that
that they just can't succeed in their
their uh their public schools well how
are they exceeding in in the in their
new
in their new environments well i guess
we'll never know because uh because the
law um
doesn't allow us to and the bill to uh
to provide some transparency there was
uh was defeated again like all of these
things were on on straight party-line
votes
so taxpayers are never going to know
how students are doing using their using
their money we certainly know when it
comes to public schools right
representative porter public schools we
know how our public schools our students
in our public schools are doing and we
know that that in in overall in new
hampshire our students in public schools
are among the best in the country we see
that over and over in terms of student
student outcome ratings it's just not
happening everywhere it's happening in
hopkinton i know it's half gonna happen
we got great student outcomes but we
don't have to go very far from hopkinton
20 minutes up the road to newport you've
got the lowest
student average performance in the
entire state um
and right above that and it's just a
scoach above that is the average student
in manchester and that's a complete
disservice for for the state and sort of
viewing off where where we are but we
know but in fact we know
how our public schools are doing and
based on
the current law we're never going to
know how students with vouchers are
doing
and then finally
um
and i've probably missed a few
the fact that we're we're letting 10
of our precious state dollars fly out
basically being being carved right off
the top
and retained within the scholarship
organization to for their own purposes
and it's got to be closing in a million
bucks and it's going to be a lot higher
than that
um
to uh to be retained by an organization
that has a current the form of state rep
on their board of directors
so um so
for for these reasons mr chair
i honestly don't see how this this
program succeeds in the long run even in
the show i mean it it it's probably
gonna
gonna keep going on
um given the uh given the current
composition of the um of the legislature
but uh but i don't see how it extends
beyond that unless we can really get
serious about looking after taxpayer
dollars and and looking after the the
the safety the welfare and the
performance outcomes of our students
across the state thank you
thank you uh representative boom
thank you mr chairman uh
the accountability
issue
same issue we had when we started
charter schools the same argument
parents
can take their kids out of the efa
they can take their kids out of charter
schools that's the accountability that
public schools don't have because in a
lot of cases parents can't take their
kids out of public school unless they
have someplace else to take them in a
lot of places there isn't any place else
to take them so the efa is a good point
for the parents to get their
accountability
it goes and yet public schools are doing
good in some places not in all
and
um
and that's compared to 10 years ago and
not doing that good now so anyway so
that's just one
the best thing is with the efa the
parents can determine what is best for
the student if they don't like where
they're sending the student they can
move them they can send them back to the
public school so that's
where to get parental choice
thank you
i'm glad you're back
very often when we have bills when they
are no longer needed we itl them
many of these bills we itl today were
done because the rules are already in
place and they are unnecessary
and in fact there was a bill that
michael moff and i were both sponsors uh
co-sponsors of because it was needed but
it was cleared up in rules and we itl
that as well because that's what you do
you don't then pass a bill that's on
something that's already been done it's
unnecessary and so quite a few of those
thousand cuts were not passed because
they were unnecessary as far as the
um
background checks goes
we already had that discussion
the the doe is not ready yet they said
give them some time in the meantime yes
parents should use their common sense
and it says and it was stated
what each thing was
right the on the list what the rule what
they did what what what background
checks there were or not so parents
could decide they're not doing back
check background checks i'm not sending
my kid there that's all clear open and
transparent
and then the
the whole thing with oh well we can't
know
[Music]
we can't know you know we we we just got
rid of
and don't let parents know what's going
on i already said it is already
published
okay they did it yesterday it's there
it's easy it's in the parent document
it's in the application program it's
there why are we passing a law to do
something that's there so many of these
things they're already being done why
are we passing laws to do something
that's already done so no we're not
cutting the
thousand cutting the thing by not doing
all these things they were already done
these bills were premature
when they were written they made a lot
of sense because we didn't have the
rules then we have the rules now we have
the rules now so the bills are no longer
necessary so we itl them just like we
itld our own bill because it's no longer
necessary
but as far as money goes
i hear all the time from members on this
committee how much we need to help the
poor kids how much we need to give more
money to the poor kids i remember last
year that one of the problems
was that oh we're going to be taking all
these kids out of the public schools and
that was the problem well guess what we
didn't take that many immediately this
this immediate time out of the public
schools they left most of them the year
before but now the problem is we didn't
take them out of the public schools i
don't get you know well we did or we
didn't either way it's a problem i guess
it's just a way to argue and kill this
thing that's helping lots of kids the
other part of it is aren't we supposed
to be helping kids in need what about
the parent who was here multiple times
whose kid was sent out of the public
school because of his mental
disabilities who tried to go to another
public school and they wouldn't take him
because of his mental disabilities who
tried to go to a private school and
they wouldn't take him because of his
mental disabilities and the mom is now
homeschooling should she not get some
support for the state for that kid since
they're letting her down in all the rest
of the ways
i mean this is money that was this is
state money this is not
local money and we keep hearing the
signs out there from misinformation
going around we're stealing money from
the public schools we're killing the
public schools well obviously we're not
that not that many kids left this year
and we're not taking any of the local
money those parents are still paying
their taxes they're paying local taxes
to send other kids to school
and having to educate their own kids and
provide for their own kids because it's
not working for them in the public
schools and we can't even give them the
state money that's supposed to provide
an adequate education for all the
students in the state i believe when you
were when when the bill was being
presented
about the new way of funding i forget
which number that is what the foundation
i heard multiple quotes every child in
this state is one of our children these
are all our children we need to make
sure every single child in the state
gets an adequate education and yet we're
refusing we want to take away
this money that's much less than than is
being paid in the public schools we want
to take this state money away from those
kids who can't otherwise get an adequate
education
i don't understand
i don't understand where anybody is
coming from you heard all those kids you
heard all those parents the problems
they had the reason they couldn't get an
education in the public school the
advantages that they were having now how
much better they're doing now and you
just want to say oh sorry you got to go
back to the public school
uh yeah we know you can't afford to go
to a
private school so we're just not going
to help you you got to go back to the
public school which wasn't working for
you i mean i thought this was about
educating kids
and it looks like it's not
thank you very much
is there is any more discussion from the
committee
lastly just to correct one thing which
was mentioned
uh we do want accountability
and the
uh bill which came forward to us
there are three ways to identify
accountability
for a student in the efa program as
there is in other programs here one to
have the standardized norm referenced
test administered
that was eliminated in that amendment
and we're anxious to see
tools that are aligned with
what the curriculum is all about so
we're assessing the curriculum not
necessarily some norm referenced test
which is necessarily aligned around
the state or the federal government
and so
the test we use statewide here is also
norm reference test so we just
eliminated one of the
the instruments
and it's a shame that we
measure progress we look at progress
based on an instrument that's given once
a year in the spring we don't see the
results until the fall
we eliminated or it was an attempt to
eliminate the opportunity to use the
norm reference test which afforded like
the
some of the tests which we are using
within the school districts right now
the star math star reading which can be
given four times a year at various times
and measure growth and see where the
student is
secondly the eliminating of a portfolio
of work that's been achieved and
completed by a student
that is a wonderful way to determine
that the student knows how to apply the
skills and now it's the learning through
their program
and it's an excellent way to see whether
we are hitting the mark
sometimes these numbers we see on tests
are not really reflective of what its
students able to do because we have
different styles of learning and
different styles of teaching
so i i think there was a lot done today
we also looked at several of the bills
uh including the bill
that dealt with 1376 which dealt with
disabilities and we've asked that some
amending language come forward so that
we can better address the issue which
was presented in that particular bill
we're also looking at
yes we believe that parents should be
informed what a
particular provider in an efa program
does provide and some of the background
of them we like the idea of profile the
the profiles uh directory and profiles
of the providers that be placed there
but a laundry list of uh issues or
elements within that which don't
necessarily apply to both online or or
those uh ways of teaching one-to-one
with a child or in a small group
they're different
and so
let's be honest with folks and try to
develop something which really reflects
what parents might be interested to help
them in selecting an efa program
so i think that there is a lot of
a desire to work together to try to
develop a program which best fits the
child who's looking for it we cannot
afford to lose any children in the state
with 1800 students participating in that
program right now that's 1800 adults
that will later go on and become part of
and
not annually but they will go on
we need to have everybody prepared we
can't afford in a state where our
demographic is sliding down
we've lost how many since
20 30 years ago
huge number of students
we need them to to attract businesses to
the state so
the efa is just one of the options one
of the alternative programs that we can
offer students and keep kids in school
and provide the best fit and the best
form of instruction that they need so
i'm proud of what we're doing i'm proud
of the direction that we are going in
and i hope that we can continue to work
together as a committee to try to find
resolution on some of these areas where
we've asked that we come back and work
together on amending language
so
is there any further discussion yes
representative litchfield
just on a
sorry on a positive note and some food
for thought i have children both in
public and private schools and i think
the majority vast majority of parents
prefer their child to be the local
public school because quite honestly
that's how you become part of the
community right
that being said though i just want to
share that when it comes to looking at
how your child is doing in the private
school or how that school is doing one
of the things that i know i look at is
what are the psat scores what are the
sat scores at these schools right they
offer that
the other thing i look at is the college
matriculation i do not look at the list
of acceptances because each class you
could have one or two children that may
really excel and they could get into six
excellent schools either i don't think
that's a great barometer but that being
said i look at the matriculation when it
comes to middle schools we have certain
middle schools in our area that are
feeder schools for let's say a pea
i look at my children and i see how you
know they're doing two and a half hours
of homework and i look at the in-depth
projects that they're doing i look at
how they're starting to teach me things
now whereas their counterparts locally
they laugh at my kids and they joke and
they say huh we have one worksheet a
week of homework and homework's not the
end i'll be all i wish my kids had more
of a childhood but i just want to say
that there are other indicators out
there
that you can take a look at just to see
you know how these other schools are
working out
thank you very much are there further
comments from the committee
madam clerk would you please call the
rule
yes this is house bill 1683
repealing the education freedom account
program the motion on the table is ito
representative cordelli
yes
president of litchfield is a yes
representative bone yes
representative blakes yes rosa moffitt
yes
representative hobson yes representative
ford yes representative soti yes i'm sam
nelson
representative luno no from sam waltz no
representative cornell no
representative tanner no
representative wallner no
represent mullin no
where's ev woodcock
or is that porter
representative hall no
and chairman ladd yes
so the itl motion carries ten to ten to
nine
okay uh before we get out of here today
we had two bills yesterday
which we skipped over we've had the
amendments returned now we should be
able to quickly address those bills
one of them is 1646 the other is 1594.
um
uh let's go and do medical or 1594 is
represent mullen you had a amendment you
let me know when you're ready we all
have it uh yeah
does everybody have a copy of this right
now
there's extras right here also
go ahead representative mullen thank you
mr chair okay so just to refresh your
memories uh house bill 1594
was the bill that uh
seeks to have students who are either on
a 504 or an iep
plan
consider uh whether or not it's of their
team consider whether or not it's
appropriate to develop
a transition plan that includes how to
register to vote and what process
one needs to go through to become a
voting adult after the age of 18.
there was an escape hatch
in
section 2
which sort of allowed schools not to
have to do that if they were already
doing an alternative type of an activity
to educate students about the process of
registering and voting
we agreed as a committee that that was
probably not a great provision of the
bill
because it would allow some kids with
504s and ieps to slip through
without having the determination made by
their team
and
it didn't
it wouldn't spell out the process so
as a result the amendment that you have
in front of you now which is amendment
h
simply eliminates section two
so the bill is identical in section one
to the bill that we considered yesterday
and section two is gone okay and looking
at this i'm trying to remember i don't
think we had emotion on the table uh we
did not so uh reversing mullen would you
put forth a motion just ought to pass
i'll second it and then we'll go with
the amendment following that certainly
uh thank you mr chair i move that we
ought to pass house bill 1594. i'll
okay go ahead
so as i said uh the the amendment
eliminates section two so i move that we
uh
accept amendment
no further discussion i know i i'd like
to talk about it because i think what
you've got here is the amendment that
really is strengthens the bill
um
you mentioned the second part of it was
an escape hatch exactly what it was
escape hatch away from the iep right i
don't believe the student that had the
iep would get the help and assistance
they would like to have
as a transitional step
uh leaving school and going into their
adult career or
adult lives
and this would certainly be of
assistance to them i also believe that
if we're not doing we probably should be
doing it in many of our social studies
classes or other classes at the high
schools
[Music]
injecting into the curriculum what being
a true
uh
resident and citizen of this country
really means and that's the vote that
you have the opportunity to vote in a
democracy
and and you're part of our our whole
structure of government and if you
negate to do that you're forfeiting many
of those rights you have in the
constitution
and so
i would suggest that we as as high
school people and even in the grade
schools we start talking about the
importance of you know
doing what you need to do as a citizen
and that is taking an active engagement
not just in your voting but also in the
in local government
and we find out that a lot of times in
local government at least in my
particular community it's hard to get
volunteers even for the zba or the
planning board or to come in and do some
work if you're looking at revising your
master plan
and same thing on the school boards
involvement in your community
strengthens our community it puts a
little bit of ownership around
everything so representative and i'm
really pleased she went forward with
this and i supported 100
thank you mr chair
so we have a motion on the table
uh to
oh it's the no tpa motion
um
no we gotta vote on the amendment first
we're gonna vote on the amendment first
i'm trying to rush this thing
we have a motion that was made by
representative
and second by me
to adopt
0814h
that's the amendment to the bill hb 1594
and then we'll take the the full thing
after this madam clerk would you please
call the
yeah let's do a show with hands
all those in favor of the amendment
please raise your hand thank you so
that's great
now we have at the any further
discussion on the bill on the bill it's
as amended otp a
1594.
no further discussion
madam clerk would you please call the
roll
now we're not doing a week we got to uh
we got to do the real deal here
i i know i'm happy you guys are over a
lot but i'm just gonna like okay i still
gotta do this afterwards all right this
is regarding house bill 1594 relative to
assistance to certain students with
disabilities in registering to vote the
motion on the table is ought to pass
with amendments
representative cordelli yes
representative blitchfield
oh sorry yes it's weak i'm so tired
apparently she's not um representative
beaum yes representative
yes represent moffett yes representative
hobson yes
representative ford
yes representative saudi yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
president of cornell yes
tanner yes representative walner yes
from zamboang yes represent woodcock
representative porter
representative paul yes
and chairman ladd yes
so the motion of ought to pass with
amendment carries 19 to 0. thank you
very much we're all getting a little
tired here
mr chair yes would representative mullen
be doing the uh committee report
i would hope so
if so uh you could please disregard the
draft that i might have sent you away
i it might not be worded it might not be
worded quite the same way as robson
mullin would do it so
yeah
so noted representative moffat
thank you very much
okay so uh the last bill we have to do
with is the 1646.
that's a bill that we were addressing
that
for me
yes or consent on the previous bill
on the 1594 bill
okay
uh where's the amendment
we talked about this earlier today
yeah
there it is right there okay oh you
didn't get the three-hole punch
i didn't get it either on mine over
there so
some people are special representative
mullen
yes
oh from who from terry i did i was
referred to his old school because he
caught me up there pulling the amendment
off the copy machine and punching the
holes in it myself
well it's pretty good getting a
compliment like that from a fire guy um
also representative vlad i just want to
um embarrass jennifer four and
acknowledge the fact that she has uh
received a promotion
and she is now
what is your title now jen deputy
executive or what what is the title
two
of
house
okay
congratulations
and they they shared that information
with me because i was trying to get jen
to punch the holes in the and they said
i'm sorry she's had a promotion you're
on your own
you know one of the qualifications that
got her to the ability to punch those
three holes
is that she's an attorney and so
representative waltz that if you want
another profession you can step up and
you're in line as an attorney right
yeah she was an attorney out in hawaii
and and also worked with special
education out there so she's really
a wonderful addition to this staff that
we have
she has done a lottery all those side by
sides that's the lady that does them all
for us
she is the one that
um worked with us on finance years ago
remember represent luna and she came up
with the idea how equalized valuation
per pupil and all that absolutely and
she was the girl who did that um so and
she does the research with education
commission the states for us ncsl she
does all that and
she's an asset no question we appreciate
okay lastly we have the amendment here
to
1646 um
what we ought to do is uh i don't think
we took we didn't did we make a motion
on this one it was the other one we did
today where we had the motion lead
okay so
um what we need to do is this
amendment's been put forth by uh
representative litchfield uh before we
get into action here uh any action i'd
like you to please explain represent
litchfield what was done to this
amendment what's different than what we
on line number 15 the word or has been
removed
simple right
okay so that so what we need to do is we
need to have a motion put forward here
and i'll let uh represent litchfield
make the motion uh
to for the for the bill
uh not the amendment for the bill
and then we will add the amendment on
after you make this motion okay a motion
of
ought to pass for house bill 1646 yeah
reversing cordelli
i'll move amendment
h
well we got to get a second on them oh
okay right i'm sorry okay
now you want to move uh
0.808
amendment
0 8 0 8 h a second okay there's a second
over there from representative lakas
made by represent cordelia represent
cordelia do you want to make any have
any discussion
no no
no
okay so we have a motion on
so now we have to vote on the main
motion
on the amendment excuse me everybody
raise your hands if you're supportive of
scratching out or
thank you
so that being done now we uh need a
motion
to
uh
be made for the whole package here
somebody like to make that motion
representative litchfield would you like
to make the motion yes please ought to
okay we have a motion made to pass 1646
with amendment 0808 h
made by representative litchfield and
second by representative cordelli
further discussion
not seeing any uh madam clark please
call the roll
this is regarding house bill 1646 with
amendment 0808h
relative to representation on a
cooperative school district board the
motion on the table is ought to pass
with amendment representative cordelli
yes representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative lakers yes represent
moffitt
yes representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes representative soti yes robert sam
nelson yes
for sam lou now yes
yes
representative cornell yes
representative tiener yes representative
walder yes
roseanne mullen yes roxanne woodcock
represent porter
president hall yes and chairman ladd yes
so the motion of ought to pass with
amendment passes 19 to zero
thank you very much uh
consent consent no any problems okay
thank you
um
here's an announcement for the committee
here
regarding friday in this
storm we're supposed to get
uh which we may get i don't want to wish
it here
we have scheduled hearings that morning
in rep's hall
and we had several options one of which
to
reschedule if we have to if we have to
cancel that we have to reschedule into
the following
week
and
and that is going to be very difficult
to do seeing jen how many days do we
have to wait we'd have to wait till it's
so that would have to go today or we can
hold that hearing irregardless
whether we get a foot of snow
six inches of snow or two feet of snow
and i'm opting to go with we will hold
the hearing
so that we will not have to work into
the following week as we've said we are
going to have a break we are going to
have that break
in a hearing you do not have to have all
members of the committee present
so um
if we have that hearing it will be held
in repsol these are the bills which we
had to cancel last time there was a
snowstorm
now there's a possible snowstorm with
these again
well we're but
but we're going to have to have this
scheduled the following week it'd be
very difficult to do a schedule we have
some people at doctors appointments we
have some that are leaving town
and others to have other you know
arrangements already scheduled
so that i don't think's in the cards
so what we'll do is we'll go ahead and
hold the hearing we've been given
permission to do so
by the speaker and by the
chief of staff
and we'll have our services available
streaming and all that will be here
and we will hold it where we have
indicated it and reps halt
and if we have enough people following
that on our committee there where we
have the ratio of uh of republican
sedans is as well as ten to nine
if we have like a six to five a majority
of people present we will go and forward
and exact those bills
um if we have the members present if we
don't then we're gonna have to rush and
get things done on the seventh
and on the seventh we're going to have
to clear up all the bills which we have
an exact as of uh thursday when we go
home
and we'll know the number it's going to
be somewhere around 2025 bills
that we will have to exact we got to
have those done because we're going to
have a session day on the 10th
we have session and then there's a
session day following that a week later
and we
well you know we can meet pla the place
is open
um and so that the ninth
we can't be doing any business on these
bills after noontime it's like any other
time when that we're going getting ready
to submit bills to go forward
um so it was just like on the first
round of bills we had to have out by the
uh what was it the
17th was it
yeah 17th and so
the date before we and they backed it
off remember to the 10th
and we had to have everything out of
committee by noon on the ninth the same
thing will exist because this go around
too by noon on the ninth everything has
to be out that means everything has to
be written reports blurbs whatever you
want to call them half be done
so hopefully we can get down on the
seventh
folks who have a little bit of time to
write the blurbs up if they have to on
the 8th
or on the
on the seventh which would be probably a
better idea because we know lindsay has
to type all that stuff or input them
getting those as an attachment is making
it much easier for her all she does is
copy paste
and much easier so uh if you have
reports that are due right now since we
last acted on these things
uh at the last session that we've done
since please be working on those right
now and get them to me get them to dave
or to mel
and they need to come to me so i can
look at them i send them all in one
folder to lindsay
and so both majority and minority
reports and it's made a lot easier for
her so try to get these reports done
am i having to chase people down it's a
pain in the bump
so the rear end
and uh i just can't continue to do that
it's just just it's it's
not what i'm going to do
so
please you know get it done i think we
can do it all i think we can make this
no we have these bills on the morning
friday friday
and no let's see on thursday
i i mean on that seventh
see the bill you see on the seventh is a
bill to exec and we put down one then
everything that's not we can exec
rather than having lindsay put every
bill down every time we've been exacting
that
perme
yeah some people are looking at our
counter so you don't have a heavy load
at all you only have one bill scheduled
they don't know the truth
yes so you know 103 bills which we've
had is a lot of bills yeah
so rick i think what you
as far as hearings though it's the um
it's the hearings right on friday and
that's it we're done with hearings then
we're done with hearings right so we're
just about there and so just uh just a
comment i guess on the the
possibility of an exact session
following those hearings
um there's those you know yeah it's
going to be a snow day that's going to
you know may affect the number of people
that come and how long those hearings
last
um you know if it was anything like some
similar bills that that we've heard
those hearings could go very very long
and um but who knows what's going to
happen on a on a snow day we can do it
on the 7th if we have some assurances
that we're not going to take one of
those they're masking bills and tax
bills
and
controversial
and if we can get the exact sessions
done well everybody what doesn't want to
have one or two or three times of going
around debating this thing
and that we can't afford to do it
right right we are going to do it
succinctly and get it done that's great
i'm all for it so so i think and and i
put it out there for consideration is um
is if it makes more sense
to uh to do an exec session where we're
not you know thinking like well we're
going to have you know six and five or
seven and six or four and three or
something like that yeah because you
know the truth is it does require all of
us
it does and you have to have you should
you have to have a majority there when
you're expecting right especially with
possibly controversial business yeah
yeah i'm all for
if we have you know one or two people
absolutely we can get a sub yeah but if
we have a lot more than that we're going
to just put it off and do it on that
monday we come back on the 7th
and
let's just do let's just do that for the
execs because i don't i don't really
think it's it's
gonna be that fruitful particularly if
there's if there may be a number of us
that our number of people who aren't
going to be able to make it on a snow
day to get subs for everybody on that
it's a little unreasonable to ask people
to sub for somebody else i got it i
understand it yeah
so
okay so snowmobilers yeah yeah ralph do
you have your hand up yeah just the
point is uh i meant i mentioned this
earlier to you on friday we have an
executive
committee meeting right patricia yeah
and i don't know if that's been that's
in the morning and i was planning on
coming if we were going to exactly
exactly what of the county yeah the
county meeting okay executive committee
with yeah representative cornell and i
are both on yeah
and that's submitted the request right
so if they also know though that on the
week of the seventh eighth you know
there's a lot of people voting i know
all right the eighth and the eighth i
would get you got to get accepted
because i have another demo if we have
yeah
i mean i scheduled it because it was a
normal day we don't meet
the best laid plans i know on a super
we're talking about looking into the
area hotels and spending the night
thursday night so we're close by friday
is very good down the road but if the if
it's dangerous and you can't drive on
friday stay home
we do not have to have a
a majority or anything like that on on
friday we just have to have the bill
heard
bills plural
and we'll get those done i don't want to
push it off any further we can't right
so
okay must be some of that new york blood
okay so um anything else for the
common good here so rick just leftovers
from today we've got 11 14 and 1376 that
are both pending amendments
uh 11 14
and and 1376
i thought maybe 1373 what do we have a
1373 we did not do we didn't do that
there was three we didn't do today right
so we got to take care of those three
1373.
1376 is relative to the best interest of
and what were we waiting on not an
amendment we needed information there
right yes i was going to get information
from the department i believe yeah i
think that some clarification is it
covered by item three
or not right
if it's not then you may need that but
if it is we don't need the bill i
haven't heard back yet all right okay
and the other two yeah are amended in
language yep
okay
so
everybody here tomorrow
good well thank you very much for
enduring
no it depends upon what happens on the
seventh
sure